Building Healthy Technology
your cell phones.  Our session
will begin soon.
At this time, please find
your seat.  Our session will
begin soon.
[Applause]
>> MAGGIE JACKSON: Well,
good
morning, and welcome to Building
Healthy Technology, an
inspiration session on digital
well-being.
I'm Maggie Jackson, I'm the
author of "Distracted," a book
about the
fragmentation of focus and the
ways we can recapture our
attention today.  I'm a
journalist by background and a
former Boston Globe columnist.
Joining me on my left is Adam
Alter, an NYU professor in
marketing and psychology, and
writes widely for the
media and has written most
recently a
book called "Irresistible" about
behavioral addiction in our
society and tech influences.
As well, joining me on the stage
is Glen Murphy.
He is the director of UX Chrome,
and
he has been a creative force
behind many
android products, from Android
Auto and
TV, and behind a creative force
in the digital well-being front
of which you've heard quite a
bit this week.  So we'll talk
about that.
And I'd also like to thank
Helen Hutton and Nancy Baker for
putting this together so well.
Just for a minute, let's start
by stepping back in history,
stepping back in time.
The year is 1905, and picture
Freud.  Yes, Freud.
Standing on the Piazza Colona in
Rome in a warm evening.  He's
watching a lantern slide show, a
medley of short films and still
photographs projected on the
roofs of the houses in the
Piazza.
And as he writes later, every
time he tries to turn away, a
certain tension in the crowd
keeps him riveted.
This great thinker, far from
home, was entranced by the
media, the precursors of the
media that envelope us today.
He was conflicted.  And so are
we.
Fast-forward to our century, and
we're wrestling still with the
promise
and the draw-backs of
technology.
So, today we're going to talk a
little bit about some of the
challenges, some of the ways in
which we can harness the
benefits, and also begin to take
more responsibility, all of us
as makers, developers, citizens,
and parents for what we're
creating.
So to start, of course, it's
really
important to understand the
landscape, understand what we're
experiencing.  So, Adam, maybe
we'll start with you to talk a
little bit about the history
of technology, and for
millennia, people
have been associating new
technologies with something
fearful, something challenging.
You know, ever since Plato
complained
that, you know, the written word
would undermine our memories
that were so important in oral
culture.
So, how serious are the problems
of our time?  Why should we be
paying attention?
>> ADAM ALTER: Well, if you
think of that evolution, human
evolution, things that are novel
are obviously very scary because
we haven't yet tested them out.
We don't know if they're there
to help us, hurt us, or if
they're neutral.  And so any
time something new comes along,
there's an instinct of panic in
some sense, and that's where we
are here again.  And we've had
that all through a time.
In the 20th century, it was TV
and pinball machines and video
games.
One of the questions people
ask all the time, I think quite
validly is, is this different?
Are we talking about something
different now in the last ten or
15 years, or is this just the
latest moral panic that we're
all dealing with?
I think there are some things
that make this different.  I
think for sheer scope, we're
talking about experiences that
billions of us enjoy, or
sometimes don't enjoy.  You
know, for hours and hours and
hours of the day.  So the
average American spends -- the
average American adult spends
four hours every day glued to a
phone screen.  So that's taking
up a huge amount of the waking
day.  So we should understand
that I think quite well.
Another thing that's different,
I think, is that if you think
about these past technologies,
we've left most of them at home.
So even if you watched a lot of
TV, that was bound to a
particular place.
But now we wear our devices.
And so, if you ask people -- if
you ask, again, adults in the
developed world how much time do
you spend with
your phone, 75% of adults will
say that 24 hours a day, they
can reach their phones without
having to move their feet, which
is not hugely surprising, but it
suggests there's something a bit
different about what we're
experience experiencing now.
It's not the pinball machine at
the arcade.  It's the phone
that's almost a part of you, an
extension of you.
So I think there are a number of
features that make this
different.  We're also much more
sophisticated in developing
technologies than we ever were.
We understand human psychology
better.  As a psychologist who's
consulted on a number of these
projects, I know how much we
know, how much we understand
about what drives humans.  So I
think there are some features
that make this a bit different
from what we've experienced in
the past.
>> MAGGIE JACKSON: Right.
The degree of penetration, the
fact that we're inhabiting this,
it's total.  It's total.  As
well as the rapid change.  I
think that's a really important
point.
So, Glen, in order to, you know,
come out with all of the new
changes, you have to keep your
finger on the pulse.  Tell us a
little bit about the research
that, for instance, has gone
into the announcements this week
related to digital well-being.
You know, are people feeling
helpless
in their devices, or empowered,
or both?
>> GLEN MURPHY: It's a really
exciting time for us.
You probably saw them talk about
fear of missing out and the joy
of missing out.  The joy of
missing out, the title of
the research that we had done.
It was really interesting, we
went out, we saw how people
engaged with technology in the
world, and we saw, you know,
many of the things that we see,
which is sort of once your head
is down in the phone, it's sort
of very easy to stay there.
There are many things, many
exciting things in there that
keep you in there.
But I think the other part that
we saw that was really
interesting was just how social
factors became a large part of
this.
Unlike TV or even desktop
computing, which were relatively
solitary things, a phone is an
inherently social object.  And
so one of the key things that we
saw was that even if there was
nothing for you to do on your
phone, you still kept it nearby
because there were other people
who were trying to reach you,
and so we all became part of
this big mesh of humans
contacting each other, and I
think that was something that we
had underestimated in all of
this, the role
of each other in this area.
>> MAGGIE JACKSON: I think
-- well, actually, when cell
phones first came out, I used to
joke that people should -- who
are buying them, maybe you
haven't heard of Radio Shack,
but we
used to buy phones at Radio
Shack.  The guy at the store
should take you
in the back and give you
counseling, just like the
minister might when you get
married.  Here's what you need
to know.
So I think -- yeah, that's
really important then.
What about the emotional factors
related to these feedback loops?
Can you just elaborate a little
bit
about -- because it's really
complex, and we are right in the
middle of it, and it reminds me
also of books.  You know, when
you're reading a book, the
content is where your attention
lies.  But there is a technology
around it that affects you.
It's a lot less static than
people think.
So, you know, what are we not
aware of in terms of our
emotional responses?
And were you surprised at the
myriad of responses that people
had?
>> GLEN MURPHY: Yeah. This
whole space is, like, really
interesting, because there are
some deeply individual responses
in here.
I think it's really hard to draw
broad generalizations.  But the
feedback thing I think is really
interesting.  Adam talks about
this a lot, actually,
in your book, about how we use
these devices, and they're
immensely useful to us.  They've
replaced maps, they've replaced
clocks, they've replaced writing
letters, they've replaced all of
these things, and you do those
actions,
and you feel good, they're
performing an essential utility
in your life.
But then it's sort of very
easy for those interactions to
then bleed into other behaviors
that are maybe less useful.
Or maybe they're entertaining,
and you can kind of keep going
because there's this feedback
loop of oh, just one more thing.
And so that's why we think about
how a
lot of that is very invisible to
the user.  I think you've talked
elsewhere about how sometimes
our own use of technology can be
very invisible to us.
And so a key thing for us is
how we can provide awareness to
people.  I don't think it's a
total number of
hours thing, or that's a good
indicator.  It's how you felt
about that time.  I think off we
find when we show people how
much they were actually
engaging, that they're often
surprised, and I think that's a
really interesting component.
>> MAGGIE JACKSON: Yeah.
>> ADAM ALTER: It's also
interesting there are sort of
scripts that different people
follow.  I know I have one, when
I open my phone, there's a
certain set of apps, and I'll go
in this loop back to the same
one again, and then I'll start,
I'll go through five or six of
them and go back.  You get into
a sort of lulled sense of calm
when you do that.  And I think
that's a really big part of
driving you to keep engaging you
over and over again.
>> MAGGIE JACKSON: Yeah.
Backstage, we were talking about
the auto maticity of the human
being in being a crucial factor
in what we do.  It underlays
expertise.  We have to do things
without really thinking about
them.  On the other hand, we
have to be aware.  You know, we
evolve to be as reflective as we
did to be automatic.  And that's
really important.
maticity of the human being in
being a crucial factor in what
we do.  It underlays expertise.
We have to do things without
really thinking about them.  On
the other hand, we have to be
aware.  You know, we evolve to
be as reflective as we did to be
automatic.  And that's really
important.
So, we're kind of learning as we
go and we have these conflicted
senses, and I think we don't
have the option to get it wrong.
Honestly, I think we need to
have technology and humanity
come together in better ways to
make us more compassionate,
better discerning thinkers.
So, let's turn to the crucial
first steps.
Again, Glen, maybe you can kick
it off by talking about the
android
announcementAndroid
announcements.  I thought it was
interesting that some key words
you mentioned in our preliminary
talks were control and
awareness.  You mentioned
awareness.
But how are some of the, you
know, wind-down and shush going
to give people more control?
And do you have a sense that how
effective will this be, or is it
a question mark?
>> GLEN MURPHY: Yeah.
So, the announcements that we
announced the other day were
around awareness and control,
giving people visibility into
the -- what they're actually
doing.  So they can be aware of
what's happening.  And then
giving them the tools to be able
to change that behavior if they
so choose.  And I think it's
really been interesting for us
as we've approached this space
and thinking about the right
ways to handle the
responsibility that we have.  In
some ways, we've been thinking
about where should that
regulation lie, should it be
technologically regulated?  And
we sort of came down to many of
these things start with
self-regulation.
I think in many ways, that
feeling of control is really
important to people, and so we
haven't provided that in the
platform historically.  There
are little bits here and there,
but we want to take that further
and give people that feeling of
awareness and control, so that
as people are having these
feelings about using their
phones, they have the ability to
change how they're using it.
And to your question about
whether all of these things will
work, I think
this is an ongoing thing.  We
were talking backstage about how
many of the things that we all
use in our life, like to-do
lists and other things, often
they're effective for some
amount of time, and then we kind
of
adapt, and then we sort of find
other ways to do things.  And so
I expect this to be a
long-running effort for us as we
learn.
It might be that we encounter
sort of different cultures that
have different attitudes towards
the phone.
>> MAGGIE JACKSON: Yes.
.
>> GLEN MURPHY: And dealing
with that is really interesting.
Even going back to the
pre-smartphone era, there were
many places where the attitude
of dealing with a ringing phone
was very different.  In some
places, you always had to answer
it regardless of what you were
doing, and others, it was okay
to let it ring out.
And so that sort of
responsibility of respecting the
cultural norms and helping
people think about those
cultural norms is sort of where
we're at.
>> MAGGIE JACKSON: Yeah. I
used to think about attention,
which
is a multi-faceted -- scientists
used to ask
me a trick question of, what
kind of attention do you mean?
It's a messy, big thing.
I think of it now as arrows and
one's quiver.  You can use
focus.  You can use awareness.
You can use executive attention.
But there are tools, just as
perhaps these tools.  And I
think that your announcements
are a very, very big deal.
I do have to say that -- I mean,
the
mantra or the overarching
societal push has been towards
seamlessness.  I mean, it's been
an unbroken thing.
You must engage
, or it's beneficial to engage.
To break that at all is
really momentous, and I think
that's a huge step forward.  As
a very critical person about
technology, I think it's a big
step forward.
>> GLEN MURPHY: Sorry, just
on that, I think it is really
something that's interesting for
everyone here who is a developer
to think about, is that we
have been focused on immediacy
and seamlessness for a long
time.  Like, we clearly know
that that's a
key aspect in sort of empowering
people.
But thinking about that in a
social context, creating
something that is immediate for
you as a sender also creates
something on the other side for
the receiver.  And so as we've
developed all of these things
that are very immediate, there's
another side of the equation
that we've got to think about.
>> MAGGIE JACKSON: And I
think that's important.  Go
ahead.
>> ADAM ALTER: Yeah, I
totally agree with that.  I
think there's always going to be
this sort of -- not the
backlash, but
the other side of that, the
quicker the transfer becomes in
the one direction, the quicker
you'll expect to get the reply.
>> GLEN MURPHY: That's
right.
>> ADAM ALTER: It's a really
interesting idea.
And also, this general idea of
the
role of frictionlessness and the
absence of pain points.  We talk
about this all the time in
business.  I'm a professor at a
business school.  One of the
mantras in business is make
everything as simple as
possible.  One of the best ways
to spend your money is to remove
pain points or friction points.
And that makes total sense,
because that's the best way to
ensure not just engagement for
five minutes, but for sometimes
weeks, years, even decades.
And I think we've now pushed
that to a point where we're
starting to get the initial
backlash.
It's great that these new
introduced tools allow people to
manage that a little bit.  To
introduce frictions where they
might be valuable.
>> GLEN MURPHY: That's
right.
>> MAGGIE JACKSON: Yeah, and
I also
think that it's really important
to
think about the idea of
disconnection, which might be a
change in the tempo or
the rhythm that allows you to
gain friction, but to think
about that in a way that's not
just in an on and off way.  So,
in other words, maybe we can
open up the space for these
questions.
So, we're not just thinking
about the little pause points as
being away from technology, but
importing that
discussion into the very digital
space.
And I think about that currently
in
relation to the idea of
technology.  I'm sorry, in
uncertainty.  Uncertainty seems
like a very
negative thing, but, you know,
just consider one of the
unintended consequences of
having answers at your
friendships all the time.
It actually came in the 17th,
18th, 19th century.  Now there
are studies showing hints here
and there about what it means to
have that instantanaity.  After
briefly searching online, people
seem to be less willing to
tackle a complex problem later.
After briefly searching online,
they become a little bit more
confident, overconfident, I
mean, about what they know.
They don't really know what they
know
and don't know.  I think these
are really important hits.
And why does this matter?  I
think it matters because there
is that side of ourselves that's
automatic.  The quick mind.
You know, thrives in the
routine.
You know, needs instant answers.
Does really well in the
familiar.
But did we exist on the
steady diet of the neat and the
packaged and the downloadable
and the instant all the time.
We're beginning to possibly
forget to tap into the other
side of ourselves, the
reflective, the questioning, the
skeptical, the so-called slow
mind.
And in fact, there's a really
exciting new explosion of
research into
various forms of uncertainty as
actually connected to good
thinking.
For instance, and this really
does, I think, connect to
technology and well-being.
But ambivalence in CEOs in a
crisis is shown to induce them
to do deeper
research, to look at multiple
perspectives to include more
voices, and to take bolder
action.  Wow.  And then
confusion in students.  Again,
people have always thought the
easy lesson, what's easy to
digest is better for learning.
But it's shown in complex
situations,
that confusion
leads to deeper processing in
students.
So these sort of factors fly
against
a lot of what our society
values, and I
think that, why not develop a
digital world where the human is
more inspired to say, oh, I
don't know.
Or, you know, to pause and then
jack
into that kind of discerning
self that they have.
And I'll just leave this point
with one other piece of
research, which is that when
people in the United States are
surveyed and asked, what's
positive about technology?
60% say speed, instant access to
information, convenience.  But
just 10% say a positive about
technology is that it promotes
knowledge, understanding, and
curiosity.
So, that's a really big
disconnect.
And if we could propel our other
side of ourselves into that
space with developers' help, I
think that would be really
powerful, and it has everything
to do with all the hardship, et
cetera.
>> GLEN MURPHY: Right.
>> ADAM ALTER: Yeah. You know,
if you think about the way
we stored information, say, in
the early
'80s when I was growing up,
I probably knew 100 phone
numbers by heart.  That seemed
straightforward.  You knew your
family members' phone numbers,
some other ones.  That meant
certain memory faculties were
always being used and they were
being trained without your even
realizing it.
And there's a lot of research
now, extending what you're
suggesting into the concept
known as hardship inoculation,
and it's the idea that if you
use your mind in certain ways,
if you think about things in
certain ways, in small doses,
you become much better prepared
to deal with major tackles,
major problems, major creativity
hurdles, times where you've been
thinking about things in a
traditional sense are not going
to work, how do you get around
that?  Turns out, having those
100 numbers in your head,
training your memory, that also
applies to how we use our minds
in other ways.
So when everything is absolutely
seamless and we don't have to
memorize, we don't have to try
to think about what we're going
to do next because we have a
device that's going to deliver
entertainment in the next three
seconds if that's what we want,
I think those faculties wither
away a little bit, and so it's
important to have occasions when
we do use them, even in a
low-grade sense, just so that
they're kept alive.  It's like a
muscle that's withering away.
So you want to make sure that
life isn't so straightforward
and seamless, that we're always
our automatic selves
and never our reflective selves.
>> GLEN MURPHY: That reminds
me of a conversation about
discipline, and how that leads
to developments later in
people's lives.  But I think a
key takeaway for me is thinking
about how, you know, technology
in many ways can be used to -- I
think the ideal is, and in many
ways it's
true, it helps us become more
active in low areas.  As we make
some things easier, that allows
us to devote time and attention
to things that matter.
I think the danger is that
where we don't elevate ourselves
in that way and we can end up
becoming purely passive.  There
are times for that in people's
lives.  Like, I was in hospital
for a week once, and I was very
passive for the entire week.
But I think finding ways that we
can help people be more active
in productive ways so they can
feel empowered is really key for
all of us.
>> MAGGIE JACKSON: Now,
mindfulness is a really messy
word, and everybody and his
brother has a new definition
about that.  But I came across a
definition recently that
mindfulness was not giving in to
simplifying things.  You know,
to actually dealing with the
complexity, and I like that
idea.
So, I think we're exploring how
to get a grip on this landscape.
We're also talking about
well-being,
which is a very also messy,
ill-defined topic.  But we've
talked about control.  We're
talking about awareness.  We're
talking about hardship and
uncertainty
.
These notions plug into
psychological
ideas about well-being.  You
know, mastery, control,
accomplishment, as well as
social
relationships and health.
Those are really important
components
.
Digital well-being -- what would
it look like if the United
States in five years -- or the
kingdom of Bhutan came
out with the new GDP for
digital -- DWB.  We can all
scale mountains there and see
what it feels like.  What do you
think it should look like, Glen?
>> GLEN MURPHY: That's a super
deep question.
I do think that there may not be
a global view.
There may not be a countrywide
view.
>> MAGGIE JACKSON: That's a
good point.
>> GLEN MURPHY: I think that
what we grapple with is, what
level is there a shared view?
Is it at the friends level?  Is
at the family level?  Is it
different within different
social contexts?  We talk about
use of technology, and
it can meet the exact -- the
exact same usage can mean
different things to different
people.  It can lead to a
different sense of satisfaction.
I think there are key metrics
about,
like, whether people feel that
their use of technology was
overall beneficial to
them, whether they derived value
from it.  And I think it's --
you know, there's a lot of
debate about what that value
should be.
I think we all impose our own
values upon the world as we
think through these things, and
I think it is -- you know, for
some people, the value is you
produced something.  For others,
it's you developed social
relations.
For others, the value can be
just pure entertainment, and I
think that's okay.
But as long as you are artful
and intentional about it, and
you feel that you're in control
of it, I think that's what
well-being looks like.
>> MAGGIE JACKSON: That's
great.
Flourishing, what does it look
like?
>> ADAM ALTER: I think it's
interesting, because science
generally resists subjectivity.
You want to test.  You can give
people a test, there are 12
items, you answer them, you add
up the score, and you can say
your well-being level is
average.  4.2.  Yeah, exactly.
I think what's interesting for
me in studying this topic for a
while is that
people have a really good sense
when they introspect about how
they feel about their
relationship to technology.  And
they're all using very different
metrics, as Glen said.
So, for some it's about social
relationships and facilitating
that.  That for me is a big
part.  I live a long way from a
big part of
my family, and so technology has
allowed me to connect with them
in a way that is very, very
enriching.  So that for me is a
key factor.
For other people, that might
not be a key factor at all.
Either you live close to the
people who are important to you,
or it's more important for you
to create or automatize or
whatever it may be.  So I think
there is no one definition, and
I think it will be hard to find
just one definition.  I think
the best thing we can all do is
have a list of questions to ask
ourselves, and the answers to
that I
think will illuminate for each
of us individually whether we've
got a high or low level of
digital well-being.
And off for me, digital
well-being
comes from augmenting our real
nondigital experiences.  That's
much of it for me.  So I like
social connection.  I get more
of that social connection and
better social connection with
people I couldn't have it with
using digital tools.  I want to
know where I am, I can do it
better with a map on a device.
All of that I think is a really
big part of it.
>> MAGGIE JACKSON: Right. And
there will be tradeoffs.  In New
York City, it used to be that
you turned to someone on the
street and say, where am I?  I'm
directionally challenged.
Sometimes I'm even map
challenged.  So I turn to human
beings and they look at me as
though I'm crazy.  Where's your
phone?  And they don't know
where they are.  They have no
idea where they are.
So they're really good -- there
are so many tradeoffs, it will
keep us guessing for a long,
long time.
Well, I think that -- I had an
interesting situation with a
friend that I'm still trying to
figure out where I send him an
article, but instead of
answering that he had gotten it,
it was something very close to
my heart, an article I'd written
about tolerance in today's
culture.
But he waited and waited and
waited,
and he was naturally going to,
you know, read it, and then get
back to me.  But I felt like,
wow, can't you just say you got
it?
So it was -- I just throw
that out there.  There are no
answers.  But I think that, you
know, acknowledgement
communications -- maybe this
will keep us all -- it should
keep us on our toes in a better
and better way.
>> GLEN MURPHY: I think that
exact case was something that we
saw in our own research that
wuss deeply surprising, going
back to the discussion of
technology being a social tool.
I think one of the aspects of it
that
we found really surprising was
expectations of how we use it
with each other haven't really
been set.
I think with telephones, we kind
of created a culture, like don't
call after this time, because
we're probably asleep, it's
going to ring in the house.
I feel that -- and we saw
this, we saw many of those
situations where
someone would send a message and
they
would not get a reply, and they
didn't know what that meant.
They didn't know if the other
person
was hurt, or hated them.  We saw
someone who, it took her three
hours to get back to her friend,
some amount of time because she
was busy, and when they finally
got in contact, they were -- the
friend was very upset that it
had taken three hours to get
back to someone.  And I feel
like that is a sign that we
haven't developed quite the --
that
shared understanding of what our
use of these communication
technologies really means.
I feel that because we
haven't set
that, we often pressure
ourselves into being polite
about it.  You know, oh, if
someone sent me a message, I
have to respond right now,
because otherwise they'll worry.
And that social dynamic and that
cultural dynamic I think is
really interesting for us.  I
think that's something that
we're going to spend a lot of
time thinking about and how we
can help through technology
nudge things in the right
direction.
>> ADAM ALTER: I think with
letters and emails, letters you
only got a certain number, but
emails, some people get hundreds
a day.  And so we've tried to
apply the grammar that we used
to determine how to deal
socially with letters, which is
you always reply.  It's the
polite thing to do.  To email or
to text.  And that doesn't work
if you get a
certain number, and you get unin
inundated.  I was having this
discussion with my wife.
If I get 100 emails a day, and I
make an active decision not to
reply, that seems really rude,
but I didn't invite conversation
with everyone who's emailing, so
you just never know where to
draw the line.  It's really
tricky.
I don't know if there is a set
of rules you could draw up that
would allow you to deal with
that.
>> GLEN MURPHY: Especially the
different types of emails.  Work
emails versus emails from your
parents.
Different expectation s.
>> MAGGIE JACKSON: Different
generations have different
expectations, certainly.  I
think that maybe we have to
welcome that type of
uncertainty, while keep working
at itting because it took a
thousand years for the book to
be
hammered out, as the technology
we know.
In Shakespeare's time, there was
different versions of 12 Night.
In our remaining minutes, let's
try
to look ahead, perhaps.  We've
guessed a little bit about
perhaps what digital well-being
might be, but what's exciting --
what's coming
up in the pipeline, either as a
sort of a throwing our minds
forward to the future in terms
of technological well-being,
digital well-being, or
what's really exciting now for
you, Adam?
>> ADAM ALTER: I'm excited that
there's a conversation now at
this level.  The fact that I was
invited to speak
here is very exciteing for me,
because I've been thinking about
these issues for a while.  I
used to spend the first ten
minutes of any conversation or
talk convincing people that this
is even something we should be
discussing, and we don't have to
do that anymore.  I think that's
a good first step.  When you
look people in the eye, we all
recognize that this is something
we should be focusing on.  That
goes all the way up to a big
company like Google and all the
way down to individual people
that you meet on the street.  So
I think that's very exciting.
And then the question is,
where we go from here.
I think we're really at the
beginning.  I wish there was
better scientific research out
there that suggested this is
what the damage will be.  This
is what we need to change.  If
we don't, this is what will
happen and this is how we deal
with it.  And it turns out I'm
at a very exciting point,
because I'm doing some of this
research, but I think it's some
of the earliest research.  There
isn't a huge amount out there
now.
So at the bottom of a very
tall, steep mountain, and we
will learn a lot along the way,
but not much has been done.
There's a huge amount of
low-hanging fruit, and that's
what I'll be doing with the next
few years, trying to work out
what should we be really
concerned about, what are we
talking about, because there is
some degree of panic, and then
how do we deal with it, how do
we fix it, not just as
individual consumers who are
managing our own use or our
kids' use, but also how do
companies like Google introduce
new options, new technologies,
and obviously that's already
starting in a very I think
encouraging way.
>> GLEN MURPHY: I think what
I'm
sort of excited about is I and I
think many people here,
like, the reason why we're
working in this space, is that
we want to build experiences
that people love.  I think just
delivering something to someone
and seeing the joy on their
face.  I think that's a deeply
motivating
factor for me, and I'm sure many
of you.
And I feel like part of this
discussion is an understanding
that we don't quite know yet
what it means for people to love
software.  I think historically,
we've sort of measured that very
costly in terms of, oh, if
people are spending more time
using the thing that I've built,
clearly, that must mean that
they love it.  And I feel like
this whole space is about
understanding that that's not
necessarily true.  And so what
I'm really excited about is
finding more of the evidence
that you talk about and more of
those tools and means so that we
can all go and build more
lovable software.
>> MAGGIE JACKSON: That's
great.  And I too would second
the idea that
it's so exciting having been in
the space of writing about
technology for
nearly 20 years now as a
humanist, you know, to see the
maturation of
discussion
.  I think that's really
important, too.
I would say that, just to throw
out, I think that it's a little
bit different, but it's part of
well-being, this issue of
tolerance.
And I have seen some very early
evidence that in the space of
the
digital world, more can be done
than one would think to kind of
push back on the
hatred that's out there online.
There's a professor at NYU,
actually a Ph.D.
student who's done some amazing
work in the space of helping
people speak up.  And on
Twitter, he's found that when
there's a hater, someone who's
really
espousing horrific things
online, and
then a person from their
in-group -- so, you know, if
there's a white male
espousing hatred, and a white
male who's
influential and has followers on
Twitter, makes one comment
about, hey, man, think again, or
these people are human, what are
you doing?
One comment lowers dramatically
the
amount of hatred from that
person for two months.
And that's really a remarkable
thing.  So, it speaks to a lot
of research right now.  There's
an exciting research on
prejudice on and offline, on
combatting prejudice that shows
that little points of speaking
up are important.  So,
technology that could help us
learn that or help us speak up
or understand when we're needed
to say something in the realm I
think is really important.
Another study out of Europe
showed
that if people are given kind of
an adventure game or perspective
taking, a day in the life of
Roma, a person who's a Roma, and
the kinds of troubles that
they go through, very short game
has extraordinary effects.  It
lowers their likelihood to vote
for a far right party.
It lowers their prejudice
against the Roma.
It also, for up to a year,
lowers their prejudice against
other minorities
or other pariah people, people
with a lot of negative sentiment
like refugees.
So I think these ripple effects
are really important to tap into
the virtual
world, these ripple effects that
are there.
So I think we've covered a lot
of ground, but I hope we've
raised some good questions,
something to take away, to think
about, to chew over.  And I'll
just say to wrap up that we've
certainly come a long way from
the
days of lantern slide shows and
the telegraph as the state of
the art communications tool, and
yet we're still wrestling with
the tensions and promises of
technology.
All of what we're facing demands
creative spirits, open minds,
and a lot of questioning.
And questioning is the opposite
of complacency.
And unease is really a central
route to progress in society.
So I think we have reason to
be optimistic, that with your
help, we can create a more
healthy digital world.  Thank
you very much.
[Applause]
your seat.  Our session will
begin soon.
At this time, please find
your seat.  Our session will
begin soon.
>> Good morning. Welcome to
the third day of IO.  It's great
to be here talking to you this
morning.  My name is Tim Psiaki,
and I'm a software engineer on
the AR and VR team.  Today, Tom
and I are going to talk to you
about the tools that we've built
to make AR development easy and
fast for every Android
developer.
So did you hear that the
developer
keynote AR Core is Google's
platform for building augmented
reality experiences.
You've been hearing a lot about
ARcore the last couple of days,
and I hope you guys are excited
about building for AR, I
certainly am.
Our goal is that at the end
of this session, every single
one of you would feel like you
can build an AR app.
So what we're going to cover
today is how you can get an
asset, how you can build an app
using that asset, and finally,
how you can iterate and launch.
But before I get into the
details, I
want to tell you a little bit
about something that I like to
do.
So, I really like to time myself
doing ordinary things.
I'll time myself doing things
like
ironing a shirt, or even taking
a shower or reading my kids a
book.  It's kind of quirky, I
know, but I like to optimize my
time and do these things as fast
as possible.  Sometimes my kids
don't appreciate it that much.
So what I want to do today is
I wanted to do something in AR
as fast as I possibly can. , by
doing something that I call AR
Done Fast.  That's right.  I'm
going to do a speed run through
building an AR app.  Tom, I'm
wondering if you can help time
this speed run and see just how
fast I can build an app in AR.
Now, to make this happen as
fast as
possible, I'm going to use the
SDK,
which is our new 3-D framework
that we just announced and
launched, and this framework
makes AR development easy in
Java.  So that I can sort of
narrate what's
going on, I did a one-take video
recording of developing an AR
app last night, and we'll see
how I did.  Let's jump to the
next slide and, Tom, are you
ready?
>> TOM SALTER: Ready.
>> TIM PSIAKI: We'll see. All
right.  So, let's go.  Start.
All right.
So I'm getting my asset from
poly.google.com.  I'm going to
search for a lamp post.  We'll
see what I find.
Okay, so this first lamp post
from Naomi Chen looks pretty
good.  Let's have a closer look
and see if I like that.  This is
pretty much exactly what I'm
looking for.  So I'm going to
download the model
file, and as you can see here,
I've got it downloaded and I've
got all the files
here in my downloads folder.
Now I'm going to open the
hello seam 4 sample app, and I'm
going to see if I can get this
lamp post being used instead of
Andy.  I'm going to drag all of
the model
files into my sample data
folder, and
then using our just-released
seam forum tools android studio
plug-in, I'm going to import
that asset into my project.
As you can see, as soon as I
clicked finished, we've got a
build doing that's doing the
import of our asset into our
project, and we're going to see
it pop up in the viewer in just
a second to see if we like what
we got.  There it is.  So that's
looking pretty much exactly like
it did on Poly.  And so let's
see if we can get that added in
place of Andy.  So we're going
to jump into the code here.
And as you can see, Andy is
loaded using a resource ID.
Now, you might have noticed I
actually put this file into the
assets folder, so I'm going to
change a little bit how I load
it.  I'm going to load the file
from the assets folder.
Going to drop that in, and I'm
loading
the file now, and I press play
almost.  Play.  Okay.  Done.
All right.
Hang on with the time.
Let's see what this looks like
back to.  Back to the slides.
There we go.  Okay.  So here's
our app.  So we're done.  We
have an app that's running in
AR.  We've got a lamp post.  We
can place our lamp post, we can
place a lot of lamp posts in our
office and make our office, you
know, as decorated with lamp
posts as we would like it to be.
It's looking great.  So that was
our speed run.
And so let's see, Tom, how
did I do there?
>> TOM SALTER: One minute,
45 seconds.
>> TIM PSIAKI: One minute,
45 seconds.  That's minutes, not
hours.
[Applause]
Okay.
So that's how fast we can build
with AR.
But now we're going to slow
down, and we're going to talk
through all the tools that we've
built that make this possible.
So the first thing I'm going
to do is
talk to you about assets.  You
can get your assets that you'd
use in an AR app from many
different places.  You can
source them online, you could
have an artist create custom
assets for you.  But what I'm
going to do for this talk
is we're going to get our asset
from Poly.  Poly is Google's
library for 3-D assets.
On Poly, you'll find thousands
of 3-D assets that you can use
in your apps.
As you saw, I was able to
easily
search for a lamp post and find
exactly what I was looking for.
But if you want something else
like a tree, you can search for
that, and there
are lots of trees available in
all sorts of colors, shapes,
sizes.  Maybe some
dangerous-looking ones.
Whatever you want, you'll find
what you're looking for.
But if you don't know exactly
what you want and you just like
to be inspired, you can browse
by category.  Maybe you'll find
an asset there that will inspire
you to create a whole new AR
app.  So have a look around and
see if you can find something
that you like, and I think you
will.
Most of these assets, or many of
these assets are licensed under
the CCBY
license, and so that means that
you can download model files for
these and use them directly in
your apps.  All you have to do
is credit the author, and then
you can use them.
So here I'm downloading the
model file.  And look at this, I
have an asset.  As you saw in
the speed run, here it is.
Now, if you look closely, you'll
see that this asset has three
different files.  Now, you want
to make sure that you keep all
of these files together, because
each one of these files is
important to actually be able to
render
this asset the way we want to.
But what do we do with these
files now that we have them?
Just for fun, let's crack one of
them open in Android Studio and
see what it looks like.
So, this doesn't really look
that much like a lamp post.
Maybe a little bit.  But you
probably were guessing that this
wasn't going to look like a lamp
post if we just opened up the
raw files.  As you can see,
we've got an image,
we've got some text which is
showing
what all the vertices in this
object.  You might love a file
like this if you're a graphics
engining but if you're
using a game engine like Unity,
you'd be able to render this,
tweak it, it would be great.
And I actually want to stop for
a second and let you know that
at 11:30 right here onstage 7,
or of course streaming on
YouTube, there's another
session called build an AR app
with the
Poly Toolkit For Unit, and you
can learn more about Poly and
using these assets in Unity.
But for now, we're going to
build a native java app.  We
want to see how we can use these
assets in Android Studio.
So let me talk to you about
Sceneform.
We can work with 3-D models at
Android
Studio using The Sceneform tools
plug-in.  We announced it at the
keynote on Tuesday.
So, Sceneform is our high level
framework and helps building AR
apps in java easy.
It includes a run-time API, and
that handles your rendering,
handles doing
things
with ARCore, but it has a set of
tools that let you import, view,
and tweak
your assets right in your IDE.
So where do you get this
plug-in?  Like most other
android studio plug-ins, you can
get your plug-in right
from the Android Studio
preference place, you browse for
plug-ins, search for Sceneform
and you'll find it.
So once we have the plug-in,
it's super easy to get your
assets imported.  The first
thing we need to do is place our
source files in our project.
We're going to drop them in the
sample data folder.  Now, this
is a little bit important,
because the sample data folder
is a folder that does not get
bundled into your APK.  Now, you
might wonder, why would I
want these files not bundled
into my APK?  Well, as you can
see here -- well, actually, hang
on.  I missed one thing.
As you can see, we support OBJ,
FBX, and JLTF files.  So we're
going to focus more on OBJ files
right now, because that's what I
got from Poly.
But this exact same flow works
with
FBX and GLTF, which you might
find other
places online or source from
artists, things like that.
But anyway, so we drop these
files
into our sample data folder,
like I said, because we don't
want them bundled into our app.
Why do we want them bundled into
our app?
It's because we build run time
optimized binaries that
Sceneform will
be able to use to render your
assets in android.  Now, these
binaries are optimized so they
load fast and they look great.
They include all of the data
that you need in order to render
-- in order for Sceneform to
render your models.
So that file -- actually, can
you go back one slide?
So, that is the sfb file.  So
you're going to hear a little
bit more about sfb files later,
but suffice it to say that sfb
files are the files that we want
bundled into our APK.
Okay.
So now that we have our file, or
our set of files in our sample
data folder, we're going to
right-click, and using
the Sceneform tools plug-in,
we'll click import Sceneform
asset.
This will trigger our import
wizard flow.  So this is the
import wizard.  As you can see,
this is fairly simple.  We have
three fields to fill out.  The
first is the file path to our
model, and that's already filled
out for us.
The second two are outputs.  And
both of these files are created
by the import wizard.
The first file you'll see is an
sfa file.  I'm going to go into
that in detail in
just a couple of minutes, but
this -- for now, you just need
to know this should be placed
right next to your model,
because this is going to become
one of the source files that
will show how your model is
rendered.
Your sfb file, this is what you
want bundled into your APK.  So
you're going to want to put that
somewhere that gets bundled.
You kind of have two options
here.  Your options are your
assets folder
and your Rex raw folder.  You
can put in either of these.  The
loading is slightly different
when you get to the run time,
but other than that, they'll
both get bundled, and it doesn't
matter, you can pick whichever
one you choose.
So, that's all we have to do in
the import wizard.  We click
finish, and we're done.  Let's
see what happens next.
So as you can see, as soon as we
click finish, we'll have a
greater build kicking off.
We're compiling here the sfb
that we just imported.  Now,
what's going to happen is, we'll
get these cradle tasks added.
We're picking these defaults
that we're going to fill in in
the sfa that I'm going to tell
you about in a second, and we're
building this run time optimized
binary.
But as soon as we finish this
build -- sorry, as soon as we
finish this
build, we're going to see these
sfa, sfb files added to our
project.  And so you can see,
we've got our sfa next to our
model and our sfb here -- I
think I have it
in resra right here.  The viewer
is going to pop open as soon as
you get your asset fully
imported.
As you can see, we see exactly
what our model is going to look
like here.  Here it looks like
it did on Poly, which makes
sense because that's what we
imported.  And you don't have to
deploy to your phone.  You can
just see it right away.  You
don't even have to have an app
built yet, you can just import
it right into our project in
view files without having your
app built.
And this uses the exact same
render as our run time, and so
what you see is what you get.
This is going to look just the
same on your phone.
This looks just like it did
in Poly.  I was thinking I
wanted it maybe a little bit
different for my app.  In Poly,
it sort of looks maybe like
it's kind of rough plastic
maybe, and I was hoping it would
look maybe a little bit shinier.
So let's see how we could do
that.  So I talked about the sfa
a couple of times.
So there was a text file that
you saw in the viewer, and so
that file is your sfa file.
The sfa file defines how
Sceneform will render your
asset.  You can see it has a
bunch of different parameters.
And if you look closely, you'll
see that these might affect the
way your
asset is going to look.  So
we're going to look at a couple
of these.  One of them here is
metallic, and one of them is
roughness.  And so by default,
when we import from Poly, we get
something where the roughness is
1 and the metallic is 0, and
that's going to make it look
like it's sort of made out of
plastic.  And what I'd like to
do is turn the metallic up,
maybe to 1 so it looks really
metallic and turn the roughness
down.  Maybe not all the way to
0.  I don't want it too shiny.
But I'm going to turn it down,
and then I'll see what happens.
So as soon as I save the sfa
file, we're going to rebuild the
run time
bundle, and as soon as that is
complete, we're going to see
that reflected in the viewer.
So, here you can see, I guess
this gif is sort of looping a
little bit.  But once it
completes, the viewer is looking
a little bit different.  It's
looking pretty metallic.  And
this is basically what I'm going
for.
So, I want to point you to this
documentation online.
So I mentioned a couple of the
parameters, and there are
actually a lot more parameters
that you can edit in your sfa
file.  There are a lot of
parameters that affect the look
and feel of your asset, but
there are also parameters that
affect things, like its scale,
or the way its collision works
for when you're tapping on your
object.
If you check out this page,
you'll see all of the details on
all of those parameters.  Now,
one thing I'll mention, I
mentioned how we support gltf,
fbx, and obj files.  When you
import each of these files, the
parameters will be slightly
different that you can edit in
your sfa.
And all of the details are on
this the site, so I would
strongly recommend you see which
things you can tweak in each of
these types of files.
Okay.  So we've got our asset
looking the way we want it to.
Let's see what we need to do to
get it in AR.  Now, you remember
I talked about
placing the run time optimized
binary,
the sfb in the assets or resra
folder.  Let's look at how we
would load that in our run time
out of each of these.
So as you can see here, this is
an activity that you guys are
all very familiar with.
We have an onCreate method, and
what we want to do is our model
renderable is an object that in
the run time is going to
describe all the details of how
to
render our lamp post.  You could
think of this as the run
time representation of our file
that has our optimized model.
And so what we need to do is
we need to load our file into
the run time here, and we're
using that using the model
renderable builder.
So it can take a while, and this
API is an asynchronous API.  All
we need to do is create a
builder, set its source.
Here I'm setting it to a
resource ID in resra, that
points to the lamp post in
build.  Now, the model
renderable builder returns a
completable future.  And so that
completable future, we're using
this then accept method, so that
after that's complete, we can go
and
store the renderable that's
loaded into our lamp post
renderable so that it can be
used later.
So this was for loading out of
resra.  If we were to load out
of assets, it's just slightly
different.  This code is almost
exactly the same except for one
line, when you set the
source ID, we just need to set
it to a Uri and parse out the
actual file name instead of a
resource ID.  You'll notice this
is just the lamp post.
fsb directly in the assets
folder, this is how we would
load that.
You can define a directory
hierarchy however you please and
just reference the path all the
way from the assets folder to
your sfb right here.
So, there's a lot more to
learn about
Sceneform and about how to
actually display these in your
app.  When I was doing my speed
run, I used the sample, and so
that's a great way to just try
this out and see how your assets
will look.
But if you'd like to learn
more about how to do more things
with these assets and how to
display them in the run time,
you should check out this
session.  It was yesterday,
rendering for
AndroidYesterday, Rendering For
Android AR Apps, and it's
available on YouTube, of course.
You can learn more there.
So I'm going to jump right in to
our actual app we built and take
it for a spin.  See what it
looks like now that we
tweaked the parameters in the
sfa.
All right.  So there is our lamp
post.  It's lit nicely.  It's
got everything you would expect
of a giant lamp post in the
middle of
your office.  It's looking
great.  That's just what I was
going for.
So let's jump back to the slides
now.  So I want to talk about
one other thing, which is -- I'm
asking you to
install this androidAndroid
Studio Plug-in, you might wonder
what is this plug-in going to do
to my project build?  Do I want
to install this?
And so let me tell you a
little bit about what's going on
under the hood.
So we built a Sceneform
gradle plug-in.  This is what's
doing the asset builds that I
showed you.
When you import, you're going to
add
the Sceneform gradle plug-in to
your gradle build.  You'll know
that we load this from the
Google repository, so you'll
want to make sure that's in your
project build file.  Of course,
this is the default for all-new
Android apps, so this shouldn't
be a problem.
In your app/build.gradle file,
apply the program.  For every
asset that your import, you'll
see one of these asset
definitions in your gradle file.
If you remember the import flow,
you'll remember that those look
very familiar, and in fact,
you're right, those are the
exact same paths that we had in
the import wizard.  This is all
it does, write these into
gradle.  Could you edit these
gradle files manually if you
wanted?  Sure, that would be
fine.
Now, we think that the Android
Studio Plug-in is the quickest
and easiest way to get these in,
but of course, they can
be edited and changed here as
well.
And finally, once you build and
you've got these asset rules in
your
project, you'll see that here I
am
building an APK using the
assemble
d ed debug rule in gradle, and
we have this
compile asset task, and we have
a compile asset task for each of
the assets that we added to our
gradle build, and these are
added to the dependency chain so
that they'll run before the
tasks that merge in assets or
resources into your APK.  So you
can always be sure that these
bundles will be updated, or
these optimized binaries will be
updated and ready to go every
time you build an APK, and
you'll always get the latest and
greatest version of the
optimized binary
that has all your updated
parameters
s, and that should be -- yes.
Oh, sorry.
I forgot about Source Control.
So one thing you might ask,
since we're building these files
as part of gradle, and do we
need to check them into Source
Control, where should they live?
And the truth is, you could --
you don't have to check in the
optimized run time bundles.
These could just be built as
part of your gradle build.  But
we would actually highly
recommend
that you do check them in.
Since these are tracked in
gradle and we understand all of
the dependencies and the input
files that were used to generate
our optimized binary, we can
always understand when it needs
to be rebuilt, and so if you
just check in your sfb
's, check in your sfa's, pull
down the latest source from your
source control in build, we'll
know which we have to
rebuild and which we can leave
unchanged, and so you'll have
always have the latest stuff to
run.
Okay.  So now we have our basic
app.  And I'm going to turn it
over to Tom and he's going to
tell us how after we've built an
app, we would test it, iterate,
and launch that app.  So here
you go, Tom.
>> TOM SALTER: Cool.
Thanks, Tim.
Hi, everyone.  I'm Tom.
I'm engineering manager on the
AR and VR team.  I'm going to
talk about some of the tools
that we've built to make
iterating
and building and debugging your
AR apps even easier.
First of all, earlier this year,
we
released ARCore support to the
android emulator.  So no matter
where you are, what devices
you've got, you're always able
to build for ARCore.  So, if
you'd like to develop your
ARCore app without having to
deploy to your device, get up
and walk around your room, place
your objects, then you can do
that.  If you would like to
develop in a
coffee shop or on a bus or on a
plane, then we've got you
covered.
The virtual environment that
we let you walk around in, it's
got multiple rooms, it's got
tables, it's got chairs, and if
you also want to see what it
looks like with a cat in your
room, then you can do that, too.
So, to get started, all you
need to
do is use Android Studio 3.1 or
above.
Use the latest Android
Oreo system image.  There are
instructions on our website to
side load it if you'd like.
And then it should be the
default option, but make sure in
the advanced settings that
you're using the Virtual Scene
for your camera as the back
facing camera.  Once you settle
that all out, it's good to go.
So, walking around your room,
it's not as easy as holding your
phone up and looking around.
But if you've played a lot of
video games like me, then you'll
find it really, really natural.
So you use WASD on your
keyboard, and the mouse or a
track pad, and you can
navigate like a first person
video game.
So the really cool thing about
the emulator support is we
actually run the entire ARCore
tracking stack.  We don't fake
anything on that rendered image.
We just run the full tracking
stack, which is really cool,
because as new features for
ARCore come online, then it will
just work magically within the
emulator.
So this week in the keynote,
we announced support for
augmented images, and whilst all
that stuff works, we don't
actually have any images in that
environment just now.  But, if
you get the canary build of
Android Studio with the emulator
right now, then we added this
extra UI, which lets you place
an image in your world, you can
change the size of it, you can
put it on horizontal surfaces,
vertical surfaces.  As you can
see, we didn't have to do
anything to make it work.
Augmented images works perfectly
in the emulator.
So, that helps you iterate.  One
thing we've worked really hard
on is helping you deplug your
application.  I want to show you
a tool that we've been working
on that helps building and
debugging these complex
immersive scenes really easy.
With Sceneform and Unity, we
made building your app really
easy, but sometimes you want to
go under the hood and see what's
happening.
So, we built GAPID, which is the
Graphics API Debugger.  It's a
powerful tool that lets you
inspect all of the graphic's API
commands that your application
is calling and lets you replay
them later on.  If you want to
see exactly how your
frame is being built, or see
what
resources your app is being
used, or investigate why your
app doesn't look quite as you
expect, then GAPID can help.
And it also helps you understand
exactly what your GPU is being
asked to do as well.
So here's a really, really
quick example of GAPID.  We're
just stepping through draw call
by draw call.
You can see the Andy model, the
raw resources that this is
using.  And you can see every
single GL draw elements core,
which contributes to your
final image, and you can see it
built up draw call by draw call.
So, we're going to go for a
quick whirlwind tour through
GAPID.  There are two main
stages.  The first stage is
tracing, which is
capturing every Single
single API call that your app is
making, and secondly, there's
replay which is on your desktop
so that you can step through and
reproduce those issues that your
app has.
First of all, to get going, you
need to capture a trace of your
application.
So, file, CaptureFile, Capture
Trace.  You have to choose your
device.  Choose your package.
Making sure your package is
debugable.  And then click okay,
and it will connect to your
device, start your package, and
then it will start streaming
this information back.
So once you've captured an
interesting part of your scene,
this is the UI that you get.
And you can replay each frame
within
GAPID and step through it draw
call by draw call.
For open GLES applications,
which most of our ARCore
applications are right now, we
capture from the start of the
application all the way through
until you click stop.  Use the
film strip UI at the top to
choose between the frame that
you'd like
to take a deeper look at.  And
then once you've found an
interesting frame, you can
really dig into the details.  On
the left, we've got the command
view, so this shows every single
command that contributed during
your frame.  It's neatly
separated by frame and by
draw call, and any other
parameters to those functions
can be changed and you can
replay it just to see how that
might make a difference.
In the center, we've got our
frame buffer pane.  So that
shows what the application
looks to up to the current
command.  And that way you can
step through every single
command.  We've added a bunch of
options so you can visualize
that frame buffer, but in a
different way, too.  You can
edit the histogram, so if your
application is particularly
dark, you can bring it more into
the light and you can change
those parameters.
And on the right, there are
various tabs for your resources.
So you can see the textures that
contribute to your application.
You can see every mesh.  Go and
investigate the polygon count.
You can see the number of
vertices and triangles.
If you also want to, all the
shades that go into building
your scene and the raw open GL
state, you can go and look at
that, too.
So, let's take a look at the
concrete issue, the kind of
thing you might see within
GAPID.  So, this is an example
that I created from our Seattle
office.
This is just an Andy hanging out
on a big chess set.
It looks like just one or two
androids just hanging out there.
But a really common issue on
mobile applications is overdraw.
So, overdraw is when you shade a
pixel
multiple times, that can become
a performance bottleneck on our
bandwidth limited mobile
devices.  So you generally want
to shade your pixels only one,
two, or three times.
So, how many times do we think
-- those pixels of that front
Android actually get rendered?
Well, it's kind of one, two,
three,
four, five, six, seven -- keeps
going.  It actually goes all the
way to 20.
And that's really, really
expensive on our mobile GP use.
So GAPID can let you see and
check your assumptions on how
your frame is actually being
built up.  It just lets you kind
of go under the hood and see
exactly with Sceneform and
with Unity exactly what they're
doing.
You could render your objects
front to back instead of back to
front.
So I'm going to ask of you
all who
are building AR applications,
take GAPID for a spin, go under
the hood, poke around, just
check your assumptions.  I'm
always surprised every time I go
and take a capture.
So, if there are loadable
features within GAPID, go ahead
and take a look at the GitHub.
IO link, and we have tutorials
on how you can do other things.
GAPID supports cardboard,
daydream,
and vanilla android apps as well
as the Vulcan API.
Once you've debugged it and it's
looking exactly as you want,
your next step is to get it out
into the world, so
we'll talk about that a little
bit now.
So with AR, there are two types
of applications you should think
about when you're developing
your AR app.  There's AR
optional and AR required.  Your
AR optional apps, they can be
installed and run on devices
that don't
support ARCore, but you have to
test for ARCore support if you
want to create an ARCore
session.
On the other side, AR required
means it can't be installed on
the device
unless that device supports
ARCore.
So, for those devices, for AR
optional device applications,
the onus is on you to write that
code, check to see if ARCore is
installed, and also check to see
if the device is ARCore
compatible.  So we'll go through
an example of what that code
looks like right now.
So, we have a very simple
availability API.
You go in ARCore, check
availability,
and you wait until that returns
true.  If your device supports
ARCore, you can enable your UI
widget that takes you
into your AR mode in your
session.
But before you go and check if
you have support, you should
check whether ARCore is actually
installed or not.  So we
basically have this simple API
that is ARCore APK request
install.  That can tell you
whether it's installed.  If it's
not installed, it can install it
in the background for you.
Once you've done all that,
you can
create your ARCore session as
normal.
And so for AR required
applications, they're really
simple.  There's really nothing
to do.  We go and do the white
listing on the play store for
you, so it will only be
available on devices that have
ARCore support.  ARCore is also
installed when the app is
installed in these cases, and
these
new devices are ARCore enabled,
these devices will just be white
listed automatically.
So, just before we finish up, we
would love to get feedback from
you on this session.  But just a
recap, we've shown you how
to build your AR applications
really, really quickly with
Sceneform using assets from
Poly.  We've shown you how to
iterate quickly
in the Android emulator.
We've shown you how to debug
gnarly graphical issues in GAPID
and understand what your scene
is doing.  And we've shown you
how to ship them on the play
store.
So we probably have time for two
questions using the microphones
here, if anyone would like to
ask any questions
about developing ARCore, to me
and Tim.
Hi.
>> Hi.
Sorry first for my awful English
.
>> TOM SALTER: That's okay.
>> I want to know if the update
in AR
apps can communicate with the
environment.
For example, if we can put the
shadow
s to correct direction, or turn
the lamp
to -- like the furniture around.
>> TOM SALTER: So there are
ways to do that -- the only
thing we support within the
Sceneform SDK is shadows being
cast.  They will be cast onto
any plains.  We don't calculate
where the light comes from,
though.  That would be on the
application.  That's something
I'm very interested in, though.
>> Can we tell the lights in the
apps
to make the shadows around
scenes?
>> TOM SALTER: That would be on
the application developer.  We
don't support it within the SDK.
But the application developer
should definitely experiment
with that kind of stuff.  It
will make AR apps look great.
>> Okay, thank you.
>> TOM SALTER: Thank you. Hi.
>> Hi. Is a plan that you
can download SFPs directly from
Poly?
>> TIM PSIAKI: So right now,
Poly
doesn't have sfb's directly.
You can host sfb's online
somewhere, and you can download
them into your app, and then you
can load them from there.  They
don't have to be bundled into
your app.  But right now,
they're not on Poly.
You would have to pull down an
fbx, a
glx, or an obj from somewhere.
And you could host on fire base
or something like that, if you
wanted to have an asset.
>> Okay.
So I have to go through the
import step --
>> TOM SALTER: --
>> TIM PSIAKI: Right now,
you do have to go through the
import step to turn it into an
sfb.
You don't want your asset to
just look the way it looks by
default.  You may want to tweak
the material.  You may want to
tweak the scale.  These assets,
when you put them into AR, the
scale is going to be the world
scale, and so you want it to
look -- you want it to be scaled
to the size you want in AR.
So if your asset says it's
500-something-wide, that's going
to be 500 meters wide, you might
need to scale it down.  So
that's why we think the viewer
is really helpful in order to
set up your asset correctly.
>> Thank you.
>> TOM SALTER: One more.
>> Hi.
I'm a developer for wayWayfair,
and we
have all our models hosted as
glpf's.
So is there a way to make sfb
run time, so as soon as a person
chooses a product, I download
the gltf, and then
generate the sfb or sfa's during
run time.
>> TIM PSIAKI: So gltf isn't
really an optimized run time
format, right?  So we want to
optimize that so it can
load really fast, and so it can
run well on your mobile app.
And so we don't currently
support a
way of loading gltf's, fbx's in
run time.  You would need to
convert those into
sfb's, and then you could load
them.  They could still be
hosted online or something like
that, but it would need to be
converted first.
>> Thank you.
>> TOM SALTER: All right.
Thanks, everyone.
>> TIM PSIAKI: Thanks a lot.
[Applause]
Google Pay best practices for
great paymentBest Practices For
Great Payment Experiences
>> At this time, please find
your seats.  Our session will
begin soon.
Please find your seats.  Our
session will begin soon.
>> JENNY GOVE: Hello,
everyone.  How are you all
today?  It's the last day.
Sad it's the last day?  I am.
It always goes so quick.
Good morning.  My name is Jenny
Gove, and I'm a lead
researcher on the Google Pay
team.
>> BRANDON HERRING: Hello,
everyone.  I'm Brandon Herring,
the design lead for Google Pay.
>> JENNY GOVE: And today
we're going to look at how to
design great payment experiences
with Google Pay.  We're going to
cover what we've learned with
partner integrations, and
integrating Google Pay into some
of our own products, and we'll
talk about how
you can easily create great
checkout experiences to get
great results.
Through watching many
usability studies over the
years, I'm well aware that
e-commerce experiences can be
the
high point of frustration for
users.  That's because they're
often a low point of the entire
shopping experience.  There's
friction everywhere.  You start
typing in information, but
something's wrong, right?  Red
arrows appear in the forms.
Addresses don't match, so you
try again.  You add your credit
card number, but it's wrong.
And so you try that again.  You
need to create an account.  But
the password isn't strong
enough, and you get told that,
and you need to think again.  Or
the two passwords don't match.
Or you already have a password,
but
you can't remember it.
Every one of these
experiences represents an
opportunity for a user to decide
it's not worth it.  At every red
arrow, at every point of
friction, users can abandon
their purchase.  This results in
lost sales for retailers and
lots of irritation for users.
In fact, we recently did an
audit in Europe of more than 400
top sites and
found that very many of the
basic things that we should do
correctly for forms are not
being implemented.
For example, we found that 46%
of top
sites don't implement error
messaging in realtime.  So, when
users make an error, they don't
know about it until they go to
hit that submit button, and then
they're told.  And then they
have to look for where that
error is.
It means that almost half of the
top sites don't optimize their
error messaging for ease of
years.
And we found that 29% of sites
don't allow users to navigate
back and forth
in the flow, perhaps in the
checkout experience, without
losing information that they've
already entered.
So these types of issues lead to
much frustration for users who
are trying to complete their
transaction.
So it's no wonder that 69% of
digital carts are abandoned
before the purchase has been
completed.  These numbers
represent a significant
opportunity to improve the
experience
for consumers and to create
checkout flows that bring
delight in their simplicity.
Earlier this year, we announced
that
we'd unified our payment system
and products under one brand,
Google Pay.  And today, we want
to talk to you
about how Google Pay is changing
the way
people pay for things online and
in stores.
>> BRANDON HERRING: So
Google Pay gives users one place
to easily manage all their
payment information.
From seeing their latest cards
and keeping sure that they're up
to date, to seeing their latest
transactions, Google Pay is
giving users a flexible and
comprehensive digital wallet.
Users, they can leverage this
account information to speed
through checkout.
In apps, online, and in store.
The app already has more than
100 million installs, which is
incredible.  That's enabling top
merchants from
Door Dash, to Lyft, to Airbnb,
and a lot more to enable
seamless checkouts for their
users.
And, Google Pay is powering
transactions across our first
party properties, from the
Google Assistant to the Play
Store, Chrome, YouTube, and
more.
When developers implement Google
Pay, they can create experiences
without payment forms.  Super
easy for users, really easy for
developers to implement.  And
users, with a payment method
linked to their Google account,
can check out instantly anywhere
they see the Google Pay button.
And because hundreds of millions
of payment methods are already
saved to Google accounts today,
developers can
start to implement this solution
across the globe immediately and
deliver at
Google scale.
With Google Pay, users are
instantly ready to check out the
first time they
visit an app or site or even in
guest checkout flow, they no
longer need to add a payment
method to every single merchant
that they want to transact with.
They can zip through checkout
quickly and easily.
And with less friction, the
user experience is improved,
users are happier, and
transactions increase, and we're
seeing this already validated
with a lot of our partners.
Hotel Tonight has found that
customers who were enabled with
Google Pay were 65% more likely
to complete a booking flow.
Airbnb has seen their traction
volume jump 11 times since
implementing the latest version
of Google Pay.  And Jenny is
going to tell us a little bit
about how we got there.
>> JENNY GOVE: Thank you,
Brandon.  So we're going to talk
about some of the best
principles that went into
creating Google Pay, the
practices around how you can
develop great checkout
experiences with the system
effectively, and a little bit
about how
Google Pay is enabling assistive
transactions with voice
.  Because consumer products are
dependent on the user
experience, we started with a
user-focused approach to meet
those needs.
Because consumer products are
dependent on the user
experience, we started with a
user-focused approach to meet
those needs.  We began defining
an overall vision of what we
wanted to do to create safe and
easy checkout experiences for
everyone, everywhere.
We informed our vision through
conducting foundational
research.  And then we carried
our learnings from this into our
design work.
And then we iterated on the
designs all informed through
user testing and usability
testing.  And we published
developer guidelines for our
community of developers.  We're
continuing to update and improve
and optimize our platform for
consumers and for developers.
Let's look at this user-centered
approach again with more
specifics about the activities
that we took for each phase.
So our first step involved
conducting research to
understand the broader picture,
the user's needs around payments
in their lives, and we visited
different regions across the
globe.
We went to Europe and North and
South America and we visited
Asia, and we
explored users' payment methods
and needs through conducting
research there.  We learned
about the importance of speed
and efficiency, security and
privacy, and these learnings
have really shaped the design
work that we've done for Google
Pay.
Taking these learnings, we
established a set of principles
and created a design system that
would meet those needs, and we
tested our designs with
usability studies.
In key phases of the product
development, we ran studies
every two weeks, iterating as we
uncovered issues,
and we could make improvements
to the product.  We dedicated
ourselves to the details
and to getting it right with our
users.
We also iterated through
conducting
liveing live experiments with
our partners and used this to
inform our design decisions.
Based on all our learnings
throughout this process, we
published guidelines for
developers in order to take
advantage of this work and make
implementation clear and easy.
>> BRANDON HERRING: So,
let's take a look at some of the
principles that we established
that guided us through the
process Jenny just talked about.
First and foremost, Google
Pay has to be fast.  We know
users want a quick and easy
checkout flow and experience
online.  We want to remove that
friction with a lightweight UI
that's super intuitive to
use and easy for users.  And
we've seen this in practice,
with Gametime, which is an app
that allows users to purchase
tickets for games and concerts
they want to go to.
Google Pay is front and center
the moment they encounter an
event they want to attend.
Even before they're signed in,
they're already ready to pay.
Because of this, users can
check out and purchase their
tickets in only two taps.
Google Pay loads a lightweight
UI, it shows them their account,
the payment method they're going
to use, one more tap, they're
done.  It's really fast, it's
super easy, and
that means for game time users,
all they really need to worry
about is whether or not their
favorite team is going to make
the playoffs this year.  And I'm
optimistic about mine.  So,
fingers crossed there.
This is obviously great for
users, but this efficiency also
leads to results.  Gametime
found that users who had
Google Pay were two times higher
to convert than users who just
had a payment card saved to
Gametime.  So in other words,
even when a user already has a
payment method saved with a
merchant, the seamlessness that
Google Pay can offer leads to a
higher conversion rate.
The second principle was
around scale.  So, this meant a
few things to us.  We needed to
address a global audience.  We
needed to support a variety of
payment methods.  We also needed
to create a place where users
can update their payment
information once and have it
available anywhere they sign in.
And of course, we also need
to make sure we're supporting
more than just the
android ecosystem, that we're
cross-browser and across OS,
some of which we announced this
week.
So we have to enable users to
check out quickly and easily, no
matter where they are.  With our
first party integrations, we
already support a wide variety
of
payment methods, and we're
bringing the scaleability to
developers, letting users pick
however they want to pay, from
leveraging all the payment
methods they have on file with
Google, to new experiences like
e-money for in-store in
Japan and Paypal for in-store.
We make it really easy to
implement buttons that lets
developers reach a global
audience, and we've made it
really easy to manage your
payment methods, too.  Now users
can update that information
in the Google Pay app, iOS or
Android, or on the Google Pay
web and have that immediately
available anywhere they're
signed in.  This is a huge win
for users, but it's a really big
win for developers because it
ensures that a user's payment
information is going to be
available and work any app or
site that they want to transact
with.
And, of course, Google Pay needs
to work anywhere they can access
their Google account.  So across
operating systems to Android, to
OIS, which we just announced,
and browsers, beyond just
Chrome, but into Safari,
Firefox, and more.  This expands
the reach that developers have
and it increases the user
benefit. iOS, which we just
announced, and browsers, beyond
just Chrome, but into Safari,
Firefox, and more.  This expands
the reach that developers have
and it increases the user
benefit.
>> JENNY GOVE: Now, we know
from conducting research that
one of the
single biggest concerns that
users have
with digital payments is around
security.  And we've worked hard
to give users the security,
transparency, and control
they need to feel confident in
each transaction.  The
importance of security, as I
mentioned, comes up again and
again in user research.  We know
that it's both important to be
secure, but also to convey that
security to users.
With Google Pay, we meet these
needs from the base up.  From
secure storage infrastructure,
card tokenization, and
authenticate, through
communications such as
notification, and supplemental
technologies such as device
security.  So let's take a
closer look.
As you'd expect, Google Pay
rests on Google's secure data
storage infrastructure using
industry standard encryption to
keep your payment details safe.
For transactions, we support and
encourage tokenization for
in-store and online use cases.
Users transacting with cards
issued
from supporting banks can
tokenize these in the Google Pay
app, and then transmit a virtual
account number, the token,
instead of their real one when
they pay at participating
merchants.  We've also worked
with payment
gateways and processors to
securely transmit payment
credentials online.
But beyond the actual
underlying technology, it's
important to reinforce security
through conveying information
about transactions
transparently.
We provide transaction
notifications for supported
cards, so consumers know if a
transaction is being made.
Notifications is just one of the
ways that we're communicating
transactions to users.
We're also combining the
transaction
history akrosz
kroszcross Google Pay
properties, and this provides a
new destination for users to
view their transactions.
Device security is also
important to users when
considering payments.  Android
users can use the find my
device service to remotely
locate a remote device, and one
that's associated with a Google
account, and then they can
secure that device immediately
remotely from a distance.
And in terms of user
authenticate, we're currently
exploring different practices.
For example, in the Play Store,
we've implemented user control
options for the scheduling of
authentication, as you can see
here.  Users can choose to
authenticate on purchases on
Google Pay on their device,
and set a schedule for when this
happens.
And there's the option to switch
from password to fingerprint
authentication as they purchase.
Here you can see this option in
settings, and the request for a
password to confirm that, and
then in the third screen, the
confirmation that the
fingerprint authentication has
been selected.
The user now has their new
fingerprint authentication
option as
they purchase, so we're giving
users security, but also
convenience within
their checkout flow.
Google Pay is secured in
multiple ways and we're
continually learning about and
improving the way we convey
that security to our consumers
so that they can transact with
confidence, and all of this
means that when users seek
Google Pay in your app or on
your site,
they're more likely to choose it
as a way to pay because they
trust it to handle their
transactions securely, as
well as quickly and easily.
The last principle that we're
going to review here is about
delivering an experience that's
unified.  We've unified our
services, and we've
also made it simpler for users
to get started and to pay
anywhere with their
Google account.  Specifically,
we've created a singular
destination which brings
together all of the payment
activity under this unified
brand, and in addition, we've
added new payment use cases and
functionality to our app.
When we talked about security
just now, we talked about the
principle of transparency being
important, and one way we're
achieving this through Google
Pay is with this unified
destination, for users to see
and manage their payment
information and activity.
Having an overview for
transactions and payment methods
gives users a lot of peace of
mind, we found.  With the Google
Pay app, we brought
together all the functionality
relevant to people's broader
payment experiences.
The home screen of the Google
Pay app
shows the user's in-store
payment methods as well as
helpful information like their
latest transactions that
they've made, and contextual
information like nearby places
that they can use stored loyalty
cards or stored gift cards.
With Google Pay, users now
have the ability to see and
manage all of their
payment information, from tokens
for in-store payments, to
payment methods they've already
stored in their Google account.
This is also where users can fix
anything that requires their
attention, such as updating
existing cards or
adding new cards to their
account.
In addition to storing merchant
loyalty cards, Google Pay now
stores tickets, so concert
tickets, sporting
tickets
, train and plane tickets.
These can all be kept in one
easy-to-find case, and they can
be
redeemed through barcodes, or
NFC.  Peer-to-peer payment
functionality will also be soon
fully integrated into
Google Pay, making easier to pay
friends back or family back for
shared expenses.
And recently, we've launched
new experiences supporting
mobile transit in cities like
London, Las Vegas, and
Portland, and additional transit
agencies are coming onboard,
such as tram, metro rail and bus
systems, in
Birmingham, and the entirety of
the west midlands in the UK.
And supporting transit,
loyalty, and paying friends
means that Google Pay can be
relied upon by hundreds of
millions
of users as a daily transaction
tool.
And in this, we're building
invested users and a trusted
ecosystem for your businesses to
rely on.
And this adds up to a
comprehensive payment solution
that keeps users engaged and
they're ready to pay anywhere.
>> BRANDON HERRING: Great.
So, I want to do a quick demo,
just to show how quick you can
actually check out with Google
Pay.
So, if you can switch to the
demo, please.
So, I'm going to use Door
Dash today.  Jenny, are you
getting hungry yet?  It's a
little early.
>> JENNY GOVE: Yeah,
something for lunch would be
great.
>> BRANDON HERRING: So we'll
get some Mexican food.  All
right.  I've never added a
payment method to this app.
I'm just going to get going here
.  Do a quesadilla, maybe
veggie.  Add that.
>> JENNY GOVE: That sounds
good.
Can we have something with
chicken?
>> BRANDON HERRING: Yes.
How about, let's do a burrito
with chicken.  Sounds good.  All
right.
I'm going to add that to my cart
.  And so now I'm going to go
check out my cart.
And everything there looks
great.  So, I'm going to check
out.  And this is the point
where as a user, I start to
sweat.  My heart rate goes up,
because I know there's a form
that's going to ask for all this
information.  But, when I look
here, I'm actually already ready
to pay, because I have Google
Pay on this phone.
So I'm going to just place the
order, and that's it.  I'm
actually not going to continue
because I don't think we'll get
to where this food is going to
be delivered in time.  But if I
hit this button, the burritos
are on the way.
So if we could switch back to
the slides now.  Thank you.
So, I just want to highlight
a couple
of things that I think Door Dash
did pretty well in this flow.
First, when I was -- when I
looked at
my cart, they surfaced all the
relevant details and made it
really easy to review.  This is
a really critical step to make
sure you're not surprising
users, and I'm actually going to
talk a little about this more
later.  But they made it really
easy to see what I ordered, if I
had special orders, special
requests, fees associated with
that, the tax, delivery, et
cetera.
And then when I got to check
out, they just defaulted me to
Google Pay.  As a user, I didn't
have to think about it.  I
didn't have to say, oh, maybe
I'll try Google Pay.  It just
was already there, and it
worked.  This is a huge benefit
to having to avoid checkout,
having to make users think about
it, right?  It avoided forms,
and it kept the entire flow
really, really smooth.
Of course, you can start to
leverage
this immediately with the site
g.co/pay/developers.  That's got
all the API details for you
to check out.
>> JENNY GOVE: All right.
Now, unfortunately, we know, of
course, that forms aren't going
away.  But when a user does
encounter a payment form, we've
made lots of improvements to the
experience and made
Autofill an integral part of
Google Pay.
Users really appreciate it when
websites save them time by
automatically
filling common form fill, things
like names, addresses, and
credit card information.
And so Autofill happens to
bypass all those input errors we
talked about before.  And these
can be, as you know,
particularly prevalent on
virtual keyboards and small
devices.
Chrome has billions of 30-day
active devices around the world,
and those users of those devices
are already checking out with
merchants online.  And so this
is a significant pathway to
enabling seamless payments
everywhere a user is signed in
to Google.
Our research found that by
correctly using autocomplete
attributes on your forms, users
complete them up to 30% faster.
So by ensuring the autocomplete
process is working correctly,
you can improve the online
experience for your users.
As developers, you can give
hints to the browser by
providing both the name
attribute and the autocomplete
attribute
on each input element to help
data be autocompleted correctly.
Autocomplete attribute values
are
part of the current wghtml
standard.  Commonly used
attributes are shown here, and
you can find these at the link
provided here.
Now, here are the specific
attributes for credit cards.
One thing to take note of is
that the attribute for the
verification or
security code is cc-csc,
standing for card security code.
It's not cc-cvc or anything
else.  We see that sometimes.
And that simple issue can cause
Autofill not to work
appropriately.
So, let's make sure you get
that one right.
And let me also walk you
through another example of a
common mistake we
see made with Autofill.
Now, a user experience best
practice
is so label form fills outside
of the fields, like you can see
here, and that's really good
because it's permanent reference
for the user of the type of
information that's needed in
that field.
Form fills also are place
holders, text that's shown in
the field that typically give
examples of the sorts of data
that would be placed there.
We've seen developers use
fake place holders instead of
using placeholder attributes,
and then use java script to
remove that value.  And this
makes it hard for Autofill to
determine if the user has
inputted the values versus it
being default text in
the field, and it results in the
fields not being Autofilled.  So
that's another one to watch out
for, make sure you use that
placeholder attribute
appropriately.
So by implementing these
attributes correctly, you can
help ensure that
users don't experience errors as
their form information is filled
in.  More information on
autocomplete attributes and some
of the errors that commonly
occur, we've got a list of them
there.  Some best practices can
be found at this link.
So now we've talked about users
using
their cards from Google Pay,
Autofill.  Let's talk about how
we get cards into Google Pay via
Autofill.  When a user fills out
a form, their credit card
information is saved to their
Google account, which ensures
that next time, the user is
ready to pay without having to
add any card information again.
And this saves the user very
much time and effort in checking
out.
It reduces the number of
abandoned checkout experiencing
and it grows the ecosystem, of
course, beyond the hundreds and
millions of cards already saved
to Google accounts.
By aligning Autofill with Google
Pay, we're ensuring users know
that the Autofill payment
information is coming from their
Google account.  The end result
is millions of more
people, our users who are ready
to pay, enabling frictionless
checkout experiences for users
and merchants globally, and
that's a win/win.
>> BRANDON HERRING: So, how
can you as developers take full
advantage of Google Pay?
Jenny just walked through some
really great examples of how
Autofill can really improve the
experience when you leverage it
right, and you fill it out
correctly, and you set it up in
a way that's going to work for
users.  Integrating the button
is going to make that more
seamless, because even though
Autofill is awesome, it's still
forms, and Google Pay bypasses
forms altogether.
And so to be effective, there
are a couple of things that I
want to talk through that you
guys can keep in mind
when you're designing with
Google Pay.
So, first, we covered this, it's
really worth reiterating, make
Google
Pay the default payment method
for users when they're new to
your site our app.
By doing this, you're going
to really create that truly
magical experience where payment
just happens.
And it's not just they had to do
it.  When they're done, they
say, that was awesome.  Right?
Users don't have to do anything,
and they're ready to pay before
they even sign in.  Which leads
to my next point.  Another
really easy way to streamline
the payment experience is to
allow guest checkout option for
your customers.  Account
creation slows down the process.
It's another form to fill out.
It leads to more frustration.
And card cart abandonment.
There was a recent study from an
e-commerce organization.  They
found that forced account
creation was the second biggest
reason for cart abandonment.
The second biggest reason.  It's
a very real threat to your
transaction volume, and when you
integrate Google Pay, you just
make it really easy for users to
get through and get on with it.
They don't have to think about
it, and they can complete that
transaction.
Once they have a successful
transaction, then prompt them to
create an account.  But if you
can reduce that initial
friction, it's really going to
significantly increase your
conversions.
Make sure you display all
relevant transaction details.
When a user sees the drawer for
Google Pay, that's often the
last thing they see before the
transaction, as we saw in the
demo.  So, before they do that,
you really want to make sure
you're eliminating any
surprises.
Any tax that exists, fees, et
cetera.
In that same study from the
Beymard institute that I
referenced, they found that 23%
of users abandoned purchasers
because they didn't see the
total cost up front.  So that's
one in four folks.  So, again,
another really easy thing you
can do that's just -- it's going
to have an impact.
This example here is from fancy,
an online shopping site.  It
shows a really good example of
them creating a really scannable
-- I can see my shipping cost,
and if there's tax in the total
and I can see the amount -- it's
all right there.  I don't have
to think too much.  It verifies
what I know to be true.  And
they're also showing that I'm
going to pay with Google, and in
this case, they're even showing
that I'm
going to use my AmeEx.
So it's another important
point that
you can minimize consumer
confusion.  This is especially
important when users have more
than one card on file.  There
are a lot of ways you can
display this information.
You can use the Google Pay mark
with the card.  You can simply
have it in a text string.
Whatever works for your site,
your app.  But it is a really
important thing that you can do
to just give users -- again,
we're trying to build trust
through this process and not
make users have to think and
say, wait, which card did I use?
What was it?  These are ways you
can streamline this experience
and keep users moving.
And then once they have made the
purchase, it's not necessarily
over from a flow standpoint.
They may want to go find that
receipt.  They may have things
that they need to send it to
somebody.  There's some reason.
When they go look for that
receipt or when that receipt
comes in, at that point, also
make sure you're being
consistent and you're displaying
this stuff the exact same way
you displayed it throughout the
process.
So, again, build that trust,
keep users moving, don't make
them think too much about it.  I
think in this case, you also
definitely want to show the
payment method used because at
this point, the payment has been
done, and this is going to just
give them that full context.
The buttons.  The Google Pay
buttons come in two flavors.
There's a dark button, there's a
light button.  In most cases, we
really recommend that you use
the dark button, because most
sites out there and apps out
there
are white and modern apps and
sites have a lot of white space.
So use that dark button, it's
really going to stand out more.
It's going to give users a
really strong CTA.  We've seen
implementations where there's
the white button on the white
site, and you can imagine, it
doesn't stand out that well and
users are going to miss it.  So
this is just another easy one,
the keep users moving through
it, let them get on with it.
If you do have a dark site,
then the white button is going
to work awesome.
And lastly, for really quick
and easy implementation, make
sure you're using one of our
recommended payment processors.
In the demo yesterday, they
showed how easy it was to set up
the button.  And part of that is
because these processors have
done a lot of the logistical
work for you.  They make it
super easy to get started, and
you can get a full list of these
guys at g.co/pay/business.
Hopefully these details have
given you some really concrete
things you can put into place
right now to make sure that
you're enabling customers to
check out really quickly, really
easily.  If you want to know
more, you can go to g.
co/pay/brand, and that's going
to give you all the assets and
how to use them and make sure
you're implementing them
correctly.  And at g.
co/pay/developers, you can get
more details about the API.
>> JENNY GOVE: Thank you.
So, now we're going to take a
look at some new experiences
with Google Pay.
But before we do so, let's just
stop to consider that the first
online digital transactions
happened in the mid 1990s.
So it's taken 20 years of
research,
design, and optimization to get
people comfortable with online
purchases.
The e-commerce industry has come
a long way.  And as you've seen,
we at Google are hard at work
making that even easier for our
users across a variety of
devices.  And as device
capabilities have expanded
beyond traditional experiences,
we've worked hard to adopt the
lessons
of the last two decades to new
modalities devices support.
While the same principles of
fast and
efficient, scaleable, security,
and unified are just as
applicable for different
modalities, such as voice and
conversational transactions, how
these
principles are applied must
change.
On phones, asking users to
reverify their identity before
completing a purchase may add
unnecessary friction.
While on a Google home, if it's
a communal device, shared with
family or perhaps friends living
together, verifying identity
could be very
appropriate, assuring the user
they have control over the
purchases that are made.
We're working towards
providing people with the
controls to make the
right authentication decisions
for their context.  And all of
this helps to ensure that when
users want to make a purchase
through the assistant, the
experience feels natural and
easy.
So, let's make a payment
transaction
as applied to voice
transactions.
Okay, Google, order my usual
from Starbucks.
>> Hi, Jenny. Starbucks here.
That's one tall Earl Gray.
Anything else?
>> JENNY GOVE: No, that will
be all.  Thanks.
>> And are you picking that
up at your usual Starbucks?
>> JENNY GOVE: Yes.
>> Okay. That will be $3.
45, but the balance on your
Starbucks card is only $1.04.
Do you want to reload your card?
>> JENNY GOVE: Yes. Put $20
on it.
>> Okay. I've added $20 to
your Starbucks card with Google
Pay.  Your total is $3.45.  Are
you ready to place the order?
>> JENNY GOVE: Yes.
>> Okay. I put your order in
and it will be ready soon.
Enjoy.
>> JENNY GOVE: Great.
Looking forward to that.
As new devices are introduced
and new interactions become
possible, we'll continue to
invest in these new modalities
to ensure that we present our
users with the best experiences
to
support their lives.
>> BRANDON HERRING: With
Google Pay, we focused on making
something that's fast and
efficient, scaleable, secure,
and really a unified brand
that's recognized around the
world as something that's easy
to pay.
Whether that's in-store, online,
or through new experiences, as
Jenny just showed with voice.
Google Pay gives users a totally
seamless checkout experience.
There are hundreds of millions
of payment cards on file.  And
that's a huge benefit for
developers as they start to
create seamless checkout
experiences of today, but also
of tomorrow with assistive
experiences and more.
You know, I think the future
is
definitely going to be formless
as we go into more voice, so
this is really awesome stuff
that we can do.  And it kind of
leads to my final point, which
is I do think this is a really
exciting time for payments.
There's so much coming.  There's
so much cool stuff happening.
I'm personally excited to see
what all of you guys come up
with as we move forward.
I want to call out that we have
one more session later today
that's actually going to go into
a lot more detail on the demo
that Jenny just did.
You can learn about all the
assistant actions.
And so check out addAdd
Transactional Capabilities to
Your Actions, and that is
onstage 5 at 2:30.
>> JENNY GOVE: And a reminder
that we have developer
documentation available at these
links, and we'll be adding to
these as more experiences are
built for Google Pay.
We'd love to hear from you,
so don't forget to provide
feedback on our
session on the website schedule.
And we'll be in the Sandbox
afterwards to take any
questions.
So please come and see us in
Dome G.  And if you haven't
checked this out already, you
can see some really cool
experiences of future payment
experiences, including in-store,
interactive retail experiences
that are
there in Dome G to try, so do
stop by.
>> BRANDON HERRING: I tried it.
It was very cool.
>> JENNY GOVE: Enjoy the rest
of IO, and thank you so much for
coming.
>> BRANDON HERRING: Thank
you.
[Applause]
Build an AR App with the Poly
Toolkit
your seat.  Our session will
begin soon.
At this time, please find
your seat.  Our session will
begin soon.
>> BRITTANY MENNUTI: Hi,
everyone.  Thanks so much for
joining us today.  My name is
Brit Mennuti.  I'm joined here
today by my colleague Bruno, a
software engineer on the team.
We have an awesome agenda ahead
for you today.
So by the end of today's
session,
you'll have helped us to demo an
AR app, but before we get into
that, I'll share a little bit of
history as to how and why we
built Poly.  I'll share what
Poly is and how it can be useful
to you as a developer.  And then
I'll pass it off to Bruno to
dive into the Poly API before we
do the demo.
You may be wondering, what is
this Poly thing and why should I
care about it?  I think the best
way to answer that question is
to take a quick trip down Poly
developer memory lane.
The team that built Poly was
actually originally devoted to
the idea of productivity in VR.
It was our goal to make people
more efficient and effective at
work using immersive technology.
We had a whole bunch of
hypotheses about how we could do
that, and we
figured the best way to validate
those hypotheses was to build a
whole bunch of prototypes and
test them with real people.  We
built everything like building
your docs in VR, to training
people how to use the espresso
machine in our microkitchen.
But regardless of the
prototype we built, one thing
was always the same:  We needed
3-D models, and finding the
right 3-D model was really,
really hard, especially if we
wanted a lot of 3-D models that
looked like they belonged
together. D models, and finding
the right 3D model was really,
really hard, especially if we
wanted a lot of 3D models that
looked like they belonged
together.  So we said, no big
deal, we'll make our own 3D
models.
Turns out, making your own 3D
models is also really hard.  In
fact, what you see on this
screen is the model of a hand
created by a software engineer
named Chris on our team for one
of our virtual meeting
prototypes.  How many of you
actually knew that was a hand
before I told you?  I don't
believe some of you.
All jokes aside, this got us
thinking that maybe creating
models could be easier and
perhaps VR was the answer to
that.
So we pivoted and we built
Blocks.
Blocks is an app for the HTC
vibe and
on
occulus rift.  What makes it
special is you actually inhabit
the same space as the thing that
you're modeling.
So instead of training your
brain to
think about a 3D object on a 2D
surface, you can literally just
walk around it.  Thanks to the
launch of Blocks, that same
engineer Chris that I mentioned
earlier was able to make this
beautiful fish tank model in
less than 15 minutes.
He also made this robot station
all in Blocks, and I don't know
about you, but I think that
robot hand looks a little bit
better than the hand I showed
you earlier.
You might have also seen Chris
in some of our launch videos.
That's right, folks.
One day you too can become
famous.
And as we were reflecting on
blocks, we started to realize
there are a whole bunch of other
resources for 3D assets
that could be used in AR and 3D
development.  Tilt brush is
another VR app that lets you
paint in 3D space.  You can
create everything from beautiful
portraits to entire 3D
environments, replete with both
audio and visual effects.
And we also knew that there was
this vast community of 3D
modelers out there
already making tons of assets
that could
be used in AR and VR
development.
So we thought to ourselves,
maybe the problem wasn't that
there wasn't an easy way to make
models.  It was also that there
wasn't a single resource to find
all of those assets to use for
development.  And that's why we
built Poly.
Poly is a library of 3D assets
and experiences.  And our
mission is to organize the
world's 3D information and make
it accessible to creators and
developers
like yourself
.
When you visit Poly, you'll
see thousands of assets that
have been uploaded by a vast
community.  When you upload your
assets to Poly, you have your
option to make them what we call
remixable.  What this means is
that you give other creators and
developers the right to use
your assets under a creative
commons by a license.
This means they can download
those assets, use them in their
apps, as long as they give you
attribution.
Well, the good news is that over
82% of public assets on Poly
today are actually remixable.
So what this means is there are
tens of thousands of assets
available for all of you to use
today for free under
creative commons license.
Now when you go to Poly, you
can browse by category.  You can
also search for exactly what you
need.  We recently added object
recognition to search, so you'll
find what you need
even if it isn't manually tagged
.
And when you find the perfect
asset, you can download the
file.  We offer downloads in the
form of obj
and in some cases fbx files as
well.
You may be thinking, this sounds
great, but can I actually find
useful assets on Poly?  Let's
look through some examples.
Maybe you need a sand castle
model for your vacation mode
app.
Or perhaps you want to recreate
Noah's Ark in your living room.
Or maybe you've always wanted to
include a realistic version of
your BFF Carl in your next game.
Fun fact, Carl is actually a
real human.  He's one of the
talented designers behind Blocks
and Poly.
Or maybe you're building an
archaeology app and you need a
whole
bunch of 3D scans of historic
artifacts.
Thanks to a partnership, there
are a dozen of these actual
artifacts hosted on Poly for you
to download today.  And finally,
perhaps all you ever wanted was
a politically correct
cheeseburger.  That's right,
folks.  This burger has the
cheese in both locations.
No matter what you're looking
for, you'll find everything you
need on Poly
to create a unique VR or AR
experience.  Like this VR
scavenger hunt game created by
artist and developer Harlan
Perez.
He built this using blocks,
Poly, and unreal engineUnreal
Engine.
Or these AR apps.  On the
left, you'll see an app from
developer Andrew Deutsche where
he takes beautiful flower models
from Poly and puts them in the
New York City platform.  Or on
the right, an app from developer
Ben Ferns that uses the Poly API
to retrieve low Poly versions of
real world objects in realtime.
Now, as we thought back to
Poly's mission, it occurred to
us that we might be falling a
little bit short on the
accessible portion.  Having to
go to a website and download an
object every time you needed it
for your development was perhaps
not the most efficient solution.
So that's why we built the
Poly API.  And with that, I'm
going to hand it off to Bruno to
share more.
[Applause]
>> BRUNO OLIVEIRA: All right.
Thank you.  So we're going to
talk about the Poly API and Poly
toolkit.  There's so many ways I
could begin a conversation about
an API.  So when I asked for
advice, someone said, why don't
you start with an inspirational
quote.  Something somebody
famous said that's relevant to
the topic.  So this is the one
that I chose.
A good API creates more problems
than it solves.
Does anybody know who famously
said this and when?
That's right.  Nobody.  Ever.
And that's why any time
you're working with an API,
there's a simple, but
fundamental question that you
have to ask, and that question
is why?  Why would you use this
API?
How is my life easier or better
if I use the Poly API?
To answer that, let's go back a
couple of decades.  So I've
always liked building games.  So
my friends and I would get
together
and we would try to build a
bunch of games on the old
computers.  We kind of knew how
to do the code.  But the problem
that we had was that none of us
really knew how to make art.  We
had no skills whatsoever.  Stick
figures were already a
challenge.
But somehow, we had very high
expectations about what our
graphics were going to look
like.
In reality, however, our
graphics looked more like this.
Does anybody know what that is?
It's a dragon.  Of course.
But come on.
If this is a valid hand, then
that's a valid dragon.
Now, you might think that my
skills would have improved over
time.
However, you would be wrong.
I am the kind of developer who
uses cubes for everything.
So, with my skill level, I could
theoretically make a game about
a cube that shoots other cubes
to protect the larger cubes from
being hit by the
smaller cubes, all against the
backdrop of moving cubes.
If you think that there's no way
that that game is viable, if you
think that there's no way that
that's an actual thing, it's
because you haven't played Cubic
Pilot.  Not only did I launch
this, but Google in some
official capacity actually
endorsed this, because this is a
sample
for the games API.
Now, my point for this is we all
this have book as developers in
our shelf.  It's the top of my
shelf.  Everyone has it.  It's a
best-seller.
It's called "Apologizing For the
Lack of Graphics."  Now,
sometimes we can get away with
it.  Sometimes we can do clever
tricks in our games to make
graphics unnecessary.  My
favorite one is claiming that
it's magic.
The dragon is invisible.  But it
doesn't work every time.  Users
end up noticing that we're doing
this.
Now, to some people, when I show
them this, what they suggest to
me is, why don't you just buy a
collection of 3D assets?  You
can just buy a collection, like
nice 3D assets, and then you
don't have
to use cubes or dragons anymore.
And then I say, well, this is
the traditional model for asset
acquisition.  This model has a
couple of problems.
One of the problems with this
model is cats.  Obviously.
Maybe I should go into more
details.  All right.
If you ever actually try to buy
a 3D model of a cat online, you
know what I mean.  You can't
just buy one cat.  You have to
buy super cat pack deluxe
special edition with 700 fully
animated cats.  It's very hard
the find separate assets.
The second problem is that
sometimes you're still in the
prototyping phase of your app.
At this point, in my app
development cycle, I'm not even
sure if I'm making a
game about cats or about
spaceships or even about cats
that fly spaceships.  It's a
valid thing.  So I need that
flexibility to try it out with
different assets.
And the third problem is users.
As you know, users are fickle,
and they don't know what they
want, so what happens if you
ship your app, and I know it's
unthinkable, but suppose that
you never actually thought about
cats at all during the
development cycle of your app.
And now, when it's in the user's
hand
at one time, the users want to
have a cat in the app.  How do
you do that?
Well, you would need to
somehow figure out a way to pull
out a cat from
a run-time API.
So, Poly by contrast has the
flexibility that you need to try
out with many different assets
from Poly.
It has a runtime API, which
means that during runtime, you
can go ahead and search for cats
and then present cats to the
user, or anything else that they
want.
And also, it's not a static
collection.  It's not something
that you just compile once and
then you only have the same
assets.  It's a growing
collection.  Because users are
contributing to that collection
all the time.
If you see there, you're going
to see that even I with my
limited skills made my
contribution.
Can you guess which one is my 3D
model over there?  Any guesses?
It's actually none of them.  I
uploaded this cube.
[Laughter]
So whenever you're making a
game, you need a cube, you know
where to look.
So I have this great collection
of assets on Poly, and on the
other side, we have our apps,
and we want to be able to
consume those assets.  So what's
the missing piece in that
puzzle?  Of course, what we
needed is an API.  So the API is
how your app gets access to
these assets in Poly.
Now, naming is difficult in
general in computer science, so
we put a bunch
of very creative people together
to come up with a name for this
API for Poly.  And after several
hours, we came up
with Poly API.  It's very
precise.
On a very high level, how does
this API work?  On a very high
level, it's like a search API.
Your app wants 3D assets, so
it's going to make a search
quarry.  In the simplest case,
that's going to be a keyword.
For example, the app could say I
like cats, I would like some
cats, please,
and then the API would return
some
interesting cats for your app to
consume.
Now, what happens if you're not
a cat person?  Can you still use
this API?
The answer is yes.  Or what
happens if you want to be much
more specific about the kinds of
animals that you want in your
app?  In that case, you can make
a more complex request.  For
example, you can say, I like low
complexity assets from the
animals
category, and I want them to be
ordered from newest to oldest,
so you can make complex API
requests like that.
You may be -- you probably would
not get any cats on this one,
because as we
know, cats are very complex
animals
.
You also have the option of
getting the owner's own as etc.
You can get the assets that the
user has uploaded.  You could
use that, for example, so
that the user app goes to your
scene.
So we talked about the whats and
we talked about the why.  Now
let's move on to the next W
question, which is when.  When
do we use the Poly API?
Fortunately, the answer to this
one is much easier.
How about now?
Let's do a live demo.  You
know what's the first rule of
live demos onstage?  It's you
never do a live demo onstage.
So I'm going to try and see if
this will work.
All right.  How many people
actually think that this demo is
going to work?  All right.  How
many people think this demo is
going to fail?  All right.  A
couple of people.
How many people think this is
going to fail in some like epic
and embarrassing way?  Like
something's going to catch fire
onstage.  Two people.  That's
not bad.  All right.
So here I have my demo app.
This is using ARCore and the
Poly toolkit for Unity.  This is
ARCore showing me the plains.
We have this very nice carpet
that ARCore is tracking.  And
now when I tap my finger on the
screen, I'm going to place an
object,
and this object came from Poly,
but it's precompiled into the
app.  It's like this little
intersection.
Now, since I don't want to like
bend down to the ground, I have
this hack
where I can increase the height
of this over here.  Whoops.
It's running away from me.
There we go.
So we have this little
intersection.  Now, the point of
this app is just to add some
objects from Poly to make it
look more like a real city.
So what's one thing we could
add to make it look more real?
>> BRITTANY MENNUTI: How
about some cars?
>> BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Cars make
sense.
I'm going to type car.
I made this keyboard myself.
We're going to do a search.
These are our search results.
Now all we have to do is tap one
of these cars, and now it's in
our scene.  I'll rotate this car
a little bit.  There we go.  And
I'm going to carefully place it
here on one of our streets.
There we go.
So I actually wrote some scripts
in this so that the cars
actually do something.
So if you click run, then the
car will run.
Now let's go back to results,
let's add this one.
It's going to place it over
here.
You may or may not have played
more exciting games, but, you
know, in some games, your goal
is to, like, save the kingdom,
save the world.  In this game,
your goal is just to make
traffic as bad as possible.
And the other game in this is
how many cars can you put in
this scene without them crashing
into each other?  My highest
score is one.
Let's see if I beat my high
score.  Whoa.  My high score is
now two.  Let's add something
else.  What's something else
that you would see in a typical
city?
>> BRITTANY MENNUTI: How about
a boat?
>> BRUNO OLIVEIRA: A boat.
Sure, why not?  A boat.  After
all, this is AR.  Searching for
boat.  See what boats we have.
All right.
Going to add this cruise liner.
Let's make it a little bigger.
I'm going to put this
cruiseliner here on the road.
It's going to be driving on the
wrong side of the road, but I
think that's not the worst
traffic violation that's
happening here.
Oh, my high score is two now.
Perfect.  So let's add something
else.  We will not be restricted
to forms of transportation.
Getting close to lunch.  Getting
hungry.  Let's add a jar of
peanut butter or something like
that.
I'm just making this up as I go.
Oh, even better.  All right.
Let's put this here.  It's a
giant jar of jam.  Does anybody
know what this is?  Any guesses?
It's a traffic jam.  Exactly.
It's a terrible pun.
So this shows you how you can
continue to add objects.  I
think nothing else surprising is
going to happen in this demo,
unless, of course, a dragon were
to appear and set fire to
everything.  So for those of you
who thought that something was
going to catch fire, you were
right, in a way.
All right.  So I'm glad that
this demo worked.
[Applause]
Thanks.
Now let's move on to how do I
actually use the API?
So we have the Poly API on one
side,
and you have IU app on the other
and it's naturally
cross-platform.  This means they
can get access to it from any
device that has access to the
Internet.
So we support several platform
s, Android, iOS, Unity, Unreal,
Web.
Poly toolkit, which is an SDK
for
Unity that lets you use the Poly
API.
So when you download and install
Poly Toolkit, it becomes fully
integrated into your Unity
editor.  So you're going to see
that window.  I know that window
we can browse for Poly assets.
You can see that's going to show
you -- by default, it's going to
show you the featured ones on
the website, but it can change
the filters.  So you could
filter by object type.  You
could filter by category.  You
could say, let me look at this
stuff in the transport category,
the food category.  We could
also do a search, so there's a
little search button there.  If
you need a dragon for your app,
you can search for a dragon.
If you need a cube, if you need
a cat, anything you want, just
click search, and you find the
asset that you want.
Then, once you find something
good asset that you want to
import into your scene, all you
have to do is click on the
import button.  For example, I
just click on the import button,
and now this garden is on my
scene.
Notice that this is already in
your scene, in your project, and
this is already a perfectly
reasonable app.  If you click
play, it's going to run, and
it's already like a full app.
Of course, if you actually
want the garden to do something,
you have to write some code.
Otherwise, it's going to be more
like
one of those
contemplative gardens.
But you know what's going to
happen,
you're going to ship this app on
Google
play Play, and the first thing
users are going to do is say,
sure, this garden is very nice.
However, I want a cat.  That's
what's going to happen.  So to
get the users their cats, you
have to use the Poly API.
You have to use the runtime part
of the Poly API.  So let's talk
about the runtime API.  It
allows you to run, search, and
download assets.
I have no idea what that blue
robot is doing.
This is an actual picture from
what's going on in the data
center right now.
So this is an overview of how
the Runtime API works.
First, you have to create a
request object.  You could
create the most typical one
would be the Poly list assets
request.  This encodes your
search query.  Then you pass
that object to one of the API
methods.
For example, list assets, which
means I want to list the assets
that match that search request.
Then you're going to wait for
the callback, and the callback
is going to have the results for
your search, and then based on
that.  Is, you have to figure
out which ones you want, if
there's several matches, you
have to figure out which one you
actually want to import, and
then
lastly, import that into your
scene.
Start with a basic example.
If you just do Poly list assets
as it's featured, this is the
default query.  This means you
want to get exactly what Poly is
showing on the website.
Featured assets, no specific
category, no specific keyword.
Just anything good that Poly is
showing on the website.
Then you execute that request.
Just call list assets, you pass
your request, and once you get a
callback, you're going to get a
list of assets that you want.
Then you're going to choose
among those assets in some way.
For example, you could just let
the
user pick one of them.  And once
you know which one you want
to import, it's going to get
imported into your scene.
Suppose that you want to do a
keyword search.  In our example,
we want cats.  Todays that, you
simply set the keyword field of
the request to cat, and that's
it.  Then you execute the
request, and then you get cats.
Now, by default, you're going to
get assets from newest to
latest, which normally are goods
sorting order.
What if I don't want new cats, I
want the best cats.  In that
case, I just set the sorting
order to Poly order by best.
And then you get from the first
cat to the best cat.
What happens if you are more
picky about the cats that you
want?  You can fill in other
fields.  You could specify the
maximum complexity field.
Complexity just means the Poly
complexity of the model.  So if
you're running an app in a
performance sensitive
environment, you might just want
the low complexity models.  If
you don't, if you're not
particularly strained about
performance, you could ask for
high complexity models that are
more realistic.
You can also set the filter and
request how many cats per page
do you actually want.
So, again, it's getting close
to lunchtime.  We're getting
hungry.  So of course, the Poly
API has a solution for that.
You can request anything from
our food category by using an
API call.  So if you set the
category to food, you're going
to get everything from the food
category.  Let's set the page
size to 100.
So 100 items of food at a time.
So chances are, if you run
this query right now, you're
going to get a freshly uploaded
batch of cookies, which is nice.
What happens if you're
worried about
the quality of the assets?
Maybe I don't want to serve just
any cookies that anybody has
uploaded into the site, I want
to have some criteria.
So, you could just hire a team
and have a team whose only job
it is to search for assets and
mark the ones that
are good that you want to
present to your user and the
ones that are not.  We already
help you do that work because
that's what we do for the Poly
website.
So we decided to expose that in
the API to make things easier.
So we have a fly called cur
ration status and you can use
that in your search query.  That
means that whatever asset that
has set to true, it means that
our human reviewers, actually,
mark that as being a good asset.
So if you trust our good taste,
then you can use that flag to
filter your assets as well.
In terms of code, all you
have to do
is set curated equals true.
Now we're going to have a
good problem to solve, which is
you run the query, and now you
have a bunch of choices for the
user, a bunch of cats that they
can choose from.  So how do you
actually let them pick a cat or
a dragon or a car or anything
else that they search for?
Well, you could, in theory, just
download all the models, import
them into Unity objecting, and
then show them to the user.
But this might be wasteful
because you might spend a lot of
memory and time downloading
those, and the user is going to
pick one and then never look at
the other cats.  So what's a
more economical way to do this?
Well, we have thumbnails.  So
the API allows you to download
thumbnails for any assets in our
API.  So, for example, if you
have an asset from a list of
results and you want a thumbnail
for it to show to the user,
all you have to do is fetch the
nail API
hole, and then you're going to
get a callback that represents a
thumbnail for that asset.  You
can do anything with that
texture.  You can map it to an
object or convert it into a
sprite and display on the
screen.  This is what we do in
our demo when showing possible
cars.  These are not the actual
models.  What I'm doing is
showing the thumbnails for the
models.
Once the user clicks one of
them, that's when I actually
import the model.
Speaking of placing objects,
what happens if you just place
an object in the world?  Well,
if this was a traditional app,
that's fine.  The object is
there on the scene.  That's what
you want.  But however, if we're
working AR, you need to make
sure that that object is
anchored to some real world
surface.  Does anybody know what
you can use to
do this?
ARCore Anchors.  Yes, exactly.
How did you know?  So that's
when the anchors come in handy.
So when ARCore does table
surface, it's going to report
the surface to you through API.
If you want to add an object so
that it's firmly placed on that
surface, you use what is called
an anchor object.  So what you
do is you import the object from
Poly, and then you set its
parent to the anchor object.  So
that means that the object will
remain stable on that table even
if you
move it around, it's going to be
firmly placed on that table top.
Even if ARCore improves its
understanding of the scene, it's
going to remain there.
So how do you accomplish this
in code?
After importing an asset, what
you do is you set the active
number to false.  This is going
to make it so that the object is
invisible before the user places
it.  And then presumably, you're
going to show some UI for the
user.  It's going to say, well,
tap the screen somewhere to
place this object.
Once the user touches the
screen to
place the asset, then you do a
raycast, and when you do a
raycast, you can
figure out exactly what the
position of raycast hit is, and
that's what you use to hit the
anchor.  Once you have that, you
create the anchor.
And then finally, you're going
to set the object's visibility
property to true.  And that's
all there is to it.  Import from
Poly, set the anchor, and
now we have this object in your
AR scene.
And Poly toolkit has a lot of
other features that we're not
going to cover.  It does
automatic rescaling of objects
for you.  It can convert units.
If the object is in meters, it's
going to convert.  It can get
the featured assets.  It can use
the user's own assets.  Even the
assets that the user has liked.
Change the material assignments.
If you have a different look for
your app and specific materials.
We can even do automatic
generation, so we don't have to
keep track of which objects you
downloaded from where, we
just automatically generate a
copyright file that you can
display in your app.
So let's talk a little bit
about what goes on behind the
scenes.  This is the part that
you don't have to worry about.
This is what Poly toolkit does
for you.  So, what's the
difference between the two
foxes, the fox on the left, and
the fox on the right?  Oh,
clearly the fox on the right is
sitting down.  Right?  And the
other difference is that one is
a model and one is data.
So model is a collection
that you want to render on your
screen, and data is just
characters.
The data represents the model.
Now, Poly API, of course, only
outputs data, and what Poly
toolkit does
is convert that data into unit
models.  For that, we need to
establish a format.  This is one
of those things that could be
easy, but in reality, it's not.
Because apparently, nobody
agrees on how to do this.  This
is a partial list of 3D formats
from Wikipedia.
Now, we have to start
somewhere.  So we decided to
start with the most basic one.
OBJ.  So OBJ is a great format.
It has everything that you're
ever
going to need for 3D objects, if
it's 1995.
For today's standards, it's a
little underspecified.  It has a
bunch of nonstandard extensions,
limited material support.
However, it is widely supported,
so we do offer that format in
the API.
To be a little more modern, we
have GLTF.
G It is more modern.
It has an ample expressiveness,
so it can encode scenes, nodes,
animations, materials.  And best
of all, it's a format that gets
everything right.
It's stable, it's future-proof,
and unlikely to change in the
near future.  Just kidding.
It's changed.
However, gLTF 2 gets everything
right and is unlikely to change
in the near future.
So in practice in the Poly API,
we
offer in the OBJ and the gLTF
format.  So you can choose which
one you want.
You can choose OBJ, and Poly
toolkit uses gLTF 2 and uses
that as Unity objects.
Doing everything automatically,
including material regeneration.
So we talked about Poly Toolkit
for Unity.
There's also Poly Toolkit for
Unreal.  If you're developing a
native app, we do also have
samples on our site showing how
to integrate with the Poly API
on those platforms.
So if you're developing, for
example,
this is an example of Poly
Toolkit for Unreal.  It's a
fully integrated environment
with you can download and use
Poly assets.
If you're developing Android,
you can download into a simple
AR app, and it can include a
specific Poly object on your
scene.
If you're using Web, there's
also a
sample, and the sample uses 3JS.
This is the easiest one, because
our
Poly website is also built using
3JS.  A fun fact, the guy who
created 3JS is the one who wrote
the sample.
So this just shows the wide
variety of experiences that you
can build with the Poly API.
For example, you're not
restricted to just AR.  It's not
just an AR toolkit.
You can also build VR apps, you
can build traditional 3D apps.
This is an example of a simple
escape
theEscape the Room app a couple
of months ago, just to try out
what we
could do with the Poly API and
with Poly objects.  The thing
that you notice is that even
though different people created
the different objects in that
scene, they somehow look nicely
together.  They look like they
belong to the same scene.
We also added some lighting for
an extra effect, and we got that
cheesy, spooky atmosphere that
we wanted.  The puzzles aren't
particularly hard.  I think I
just spoiled the game for
everybody, because now you know
that the
exit code is 714.
When we tried to play this game
in the office, the first person
that we gave it to just put the
headset on and said you have to
find a way to escape that room.
What they immediately did is
just walked through the door and
won the game.
[Laughter]
Because what's to stop them?
And then we had to be more
specific for the second user.
You actually have to solve our
puzzles before you walk through
that door.
That shows you some of the
design problems.
Well, for me, of course, what it
means is that I can stop using
assets
like that, and maybe upgrade my
assets to look more like that.
Now, I'm not exactly a dragon
expert, but I can sense that
there was some improvement in
dragon quality there.
So if you're interested in
trying out the Poly API and
building applications with Poly,
please visit our site.
Poly.Google.com is the site
where you can browse assets.
Developers.Google.
com/Poly is a developer site
where you can find everything
you need to start working with
Poly today, including SDK,
samples, documentation, and
everything else that you need.
So, thank you very much, and
we want to hear from you.  So if
you like this session, please
fill out the survey.  If you
didn't like this session, the
survey is optional.
[Laughter]
And that's it.  Thank you
very much.
[Applause]
Build a Successful Web Presence
with
Google Search
Build a successful web presence
with Google SearchSuccessful Web
Presence With Google Search
>> MARIYA MOEVA: All right.
Let's get started.  Hi,
everybody.  I'm really glad to
see all of you here.  You
skipped lunch to come here about
Search.  No pressure.
My name is Mariya, I'm a
webmaster analyst coming all the
way from
Switzerland to talk to you about
Search.
>> JOHN MUELLER: I'm John
Mueller.
Our role at Google is to help
the web ecosystem to be more
successful in Google Search.  So
we hope we can bring some of
this across here as well.
>> MARIYA MOEVA: Right. So
I want to start us off with an
example of how this actually
works, so you can get an idea of
what you as a developer can do
to be more successful with
Search.
So, this is Japanese website
Rakuten Recipes, and they wanted
to get more users.  They also
have a ton of delicious recipes
on their site, so they were
wondering, what can we do to get
more people to notice us in
Search?  What they decided to do
is they changed their CMS in
order to be able to mark up
every recipe that is added to
the site with structured data
mark-up.
What this does is it lets the
search
engine know that there are
different entities, so things
like cooking time, different
ingredients, a picture, and lets
us display the result in a much
more attractive way in the
search results.
And the site itself was in
Japanese, so we decided to
switch off the mark-up for those
of you who don't speak Japanese
to something more legible.  So
instead of dumplings, you have
here a party coffee cake, but it
works the same way for
dumplings.  This is how this
ends up looking like in the
search results.
You can see that in addition to
the regular elements of the
search page, so they have the
title, they have the url and the
description, they also have a
really nice picture of
dumplings, and then they have
the cooking time as well.  So
this worked out for them pretty
well.  In fact, kind of
spectacularly.  So they got 2.7
times more traffic from Search.
>> JOHN MUELLER: Yeah, and
we thought, developers usually
don't get as much advice around
Search.  And they might not even
know about all of the pitfalls
and possibilities.  Shouldn't we
share some of the knowledge with
them?  So with you-all as well?
So we hope we can show how
Search can make your project a
little bit more successful.
So, today we'll look into
various types of public web
presences and give you a broad
overview of specific details
that you as a developer can
watch out for and implement.
And these details can help make
your projects more successful on
Search, making it easier for
Search engines to send users to
your projects directly.
So, you might be thinking, as
a
developer, I don't really care
how or if my stuff appears in
Search, but probably your
customers, your users, the
people that you're building
these projects for, they do
care.  And since you control how
your content appears in search,
you can have a huge impact here.
Think back about Rakuten recipes
and what they did there.
Globally, Google Search and
Google
News send billions of visitors
each month to websites for free.
And it's not just about
websites.  We're going to be
looking into various ways that
search can work depending on
what you're working on.  The
website is just the most common
format.  You could also be
building a web app, which is
kind of similar, but slightly
different as well.  Or you could
be contributing to a content
management system, a so-called
CMS, which enables others to
build websites of their own.
Or, as a part of that, maybe
you're working on plug-ins or
themes or extensions for these
content management systems.
We'll take a brief look at this
as well as detailed
recommendations for each of
them.
As I mentioned before, Search
brings billions of visitors to
websites every month.  That's a
lot of visitors.
We serve trillions of searchs
each year, and out of those,
this is quite surprising for me
every time I look at
it, about 15% of the queries
every day
are completely new ones, things
we've never seen before.  So
maybe they're looking for one of
your projects.
And regardless of what you're
building, if search engines
understand your content, you
could get a lot more visitors
and potential customers with
Search.  So you as a developer,
you can control that through the
way that you set up your website
or content platform.  So to
understand these better, let's
take a quick look at how Search
works.
>> MARIYA MOEVA: Right. So,
in order to be successful as a
developer in Search, you need to
know at least the basics of how
it works.  And I'm going to take
you through the super high level
picture of how it works.
If you're interested in the
details, Google.com/jobs, you're
welcome to apply.
[Laughter]
And then we can go into a lot
more detail.
But, let's get started with the
super high level picture.  So we
generally talk about three
things.  First, crawling and
discovery.  Then indexing.  And
finally, ranking and serving.
I'm going to show you briefly
what each of these things is
about.
So, of course, in order for us
to be able to show anything in
the search results, first we
need to be aware that it exists.
So we have a series of systems
that are going around following
links on the
web, and downloading web pages,
html files, all the different
resources that come into making
a website, like java
script files, CSS, images, what
have you.
And those systemsfect
effectively are crawlers, and we
call them Google bot.  The goal
is to find everything that is
fresh, new, interesting,
relevant, and important, and to
do that in an efficient way.
And in order to know which
URLs to crawl and in which
order, we have another set of
systems which are known as
schedulers.
So they queue the URLs for the
crawlers to go and fetch.  And
all of this gets then stored.
So you might think that this
is a pretty simple process, but
if you start thinking that we
have to do this 20
billion times per day, then you
kind of get an idea, it's a
little bit trickier than it
seems at first sight.
In fact, in 2016, we saw 130
trillion pages.  And every new
link that we see, usually
there's two more links that
we've never seen before, so
there's constantly new stuff,
and we have to decide what to
crawl, how to update, and to do
this in the most efficient
manner.
So, whilst we find the content,
we have a series of other tasks.
First, we have to make sure that
we're allowed to access that
content.  And for that, we will
first go -- every time we access
a site, we'll go to
a file called Robos text, which
is a
pretty simple file containing
info to search engines, and it
tells you this is okay to fetch
and this is not okay, and we
obey this very strictly.  So
that's the first thing we'll try
to find on a website.
The other thing that we'll
try to do is to get as much
content as possible
without troubling the normal
work of the server, so the
website can function and serve
its clients as usual.  And then
finally, we'll try to handle
errors gracefully.  So, as a
developer, you have two tasks
here.  The first, if you
remember again, that
we do fetches 20 billion times a
day and we see trillions of
pages every year is that your
content should be really easy to
discover.  So, ways to do that,
and John will go into a little
bit more detail later is to, for
example, submit to us a list of
a few URLs that you have, like a
site map.  Or, also check that
all the resources that are
necessary for your site to be
rendered are accessible to our
crawlers.
So once we fetched everything
that we were able to fetch, we
go to the next stage, and that
is indexing.  So here we're
going to parse the
content, and into this comes
things like what language is
this page, are there any images,
is there a title, is there a
description, and other different
elements on the page.
So, to do that, we also try to
render the page, and as a
developer, especially if you're
building a lot of really cutting
edge fancy things, you have to
keep in mind that currently, the
search
systems are using Chrome 41 to
render pages.
So, not all of the different
functionalities that you might
be thinking about could be
supported by the Search
rendering systems.
And if you want to find out
more, I would suggest that you
have a look at the talk that
John did earlier today in the
morning, in case you didn't wake
up at 8:30 to see it.  It will
be available on YouTube, and
you'll be able to see a lot more
about what we support in Search
and how to render things
properly.
So, of course, given the huge
amount of pages on the web, we
also don't want to index more
than one of each unique thing.
So we have a lot of systems in
place to eliminate duplicates
and to keep only one copy of
each thing.
And then finally, we don't
want error pages, and we also
don't want any spam.  So we will
kick all of that out, and
everything else that we want to
keep, we put in the index and we
process it so that it's ready to
serve to users when they search.
So for user developer here, I
guess, it's important to
remember that key elements like
titles and descriptions are
available in each page that your
users are creating, and then
also, to check how it's
rendered.  But John will go into
a lot more
detail here later.
And then finally, once we
have everything in the index,
when users
start searching, we're going to
pool pull a set of pages we
think are relevant results.
We're going to add a bunch of
information we've already
accumulated, like how important
they are and how they relate to
the user's query.  And then
we're going to show them in some
specific order that we think is
most relevant for this user.
So, this is mostly on our
side, and you don't need to
worry about anything here.  If
your content is already
accessible and easy to render.
But if you're ready interested
in ranking and search quality,
again, Google.com/jobs.  There's
plenty of interesting problems
to solve.
So, now that you know how
Search
works, let's have a summary of
two things that you need to
remember.  First, you have to
help us find the content.  And
second, you have to help us
evaluate the content.  So, if
you're able to do these two
things, you're pretty much set
as a developer.
Now, this is super, super
high level,
so what we're going to do next
is show you how you can apply
this for each specific thing
that you need to build.
So, we're going to start with
websites, and John is going to
share with you some very
specific advice about what to do
and what not to do when
you're building a website for
someone.
>> JOHN MUELLER: All right.
Thanks, Mariya.  That was a
great introduction into Search.
Like you said, let's start with
websites.
You can build and maintain
one for yourself to kind of
showcase your own content, or
maybe you're doing that for
other people to show -- to let
them create websites on their
own.
You might be thinking that
showing up in Search isn't
really your job as a developer,
but like we mentioned before,
as a developer, you play a
really big role in kind of
putting everything in place so
that Search can pick up the
content properly.
So that's really important for
us.
When it comes to website, I
think it's worth taking a really
big step back
and looking at the absolute
basics.  So for us, that's a
URL.
Essentially the address that's
used to address a single piece
of content on the web.  Perhaps
surprisingly, URLs are the cause
of and solution to a lot of web
search problems.
Traditionally, URLs on the web
started out quite simple.
They are requests that's sent to
the server, and it responds with
unique HTML per URL.  Fragments
within the URL, so
everything after thore hash sign
here.  Java script changed that
a little bit and suddenly a
single URL could do that a
little bit more and show
different kinds of content and
provide extra functionality.
Some java script sites use
fragments.
Since these were easy to set
with java script.
However, Google generally
doesn't
support this, and as far as I
know, no supports it with
individual fragments.
So now we recommend using java
script's API to normal
traditionally looking URLs.  So
in short, with URLs, stick to
something more traditional.
Another really important thing
that comes into play with URLs
is that often you have many
different URLs that lead to the
same content.  As a developer,
that's usually no big deal, and
you can look at that, and you
think, well, index HTML, that's
obviously the home page.
Everybody developer knows that.
But for search engines, that's
not so obvious.  It could be
something completely different.
Sometimes you also just add
tracking
parameters to URLs, and all of
these different URLs are
essentially, for search engines,
separate pages that we could
look at and say, well, there
might be something different
here.  And you can imagine at 20
billion
times a day, that could lead to
a lot of inefficient crawling.
So we prefer to have a single
URL per piece of content.  And
there are two ways that you can
do that.  The first is to
consistently use the
same URLs across your whole
website.  So if you have
internal navigation, link to the
same pages.  If you have a file
like Mariya mentioned, use the
same URLs there.  If you use
anything to guide people to your
websites, make sure you use the
same URLs there, instead of
having these different patterns
that all lead to the same thing.
And secondly, one element that
you
can also use is
the rel canonical link element,
that tells us search engines or
Google, if you look at this
paging this is actually the URL
that I prefer you look at.  This
is the one that I want you to
index.  And together, this makes
it a little bit easier for
search engines to pick the right
URL.
So, we have URLs covered.
What else is there?  Let's take
a look at a typical search
results page.
So we have on top the title, the
Google I/O schedule page.  Then
we have the URL, which is right
below it.  It's a bread crumb
URL.  We'll look at that briefly
a little bit earlier as well.
And then you have the
description.  So these are three
elements on a search results
page that are immediately
visible to everyone who is
searching for something.  And
they come from your pages
directly.  So it's something
that as a developer, it's really
easy to place.
When you look at an HTML page,
they're very visible and easy to
find.  So we have the title on
top.  This is really easy to put
in here.
We have the canonical element,
which is really easy to place
here.  And we have the
description, meta description.
So while these elements don't
directly affect the rankings, or
the order that Mariya talked
about, they do affect how we
show a page in the search
results, and with that, they do
affect how people actually come
and visit your pages or not.
So, we've seen a few of the
basic
elements here, like the
metadata, the titles, the URLs,
the descriptions.  What could
you as a developer do to make
that a little bit easier?
Especially if you have various
people
who are using your website, your
project to put content online,
we recommend making it as easy
as possible for them to do the
right thing.  So not just for
you as a developer to put
titles, descriptions, and all of
that into your pages, but also
for those
who are creating pages on your
platform to put that in here.
So here you see a user interface
from
blogger with a really easy way
to add a description to
individual pages.
And we feel the easier it is
for people making your pages to
actually put this content in
there, the more likely
they'll actually do that.
When we looked at the search
results, we saw this kind of
bread crumb there as well.
A bread crumb is for us
something that is -- something
that you can provide on your
pages to make it easier to
understand where this page
belongs within your website.  We
call this a type of a rich
result,
because it's not just a pure
text result.  And there are
different kinds of rich results
that you can also use.
For example, you can add mark-up
for articles, if you have
articles on a page.  You could
tell us about podcasts, which is
really cool, because there's a
podcast player built into the
search results.  So if you have
a podcast, if you have
a project that includes audio
content, then suddenly that
content is immediately available
in the search
results without anyone needing
to install a next draft, which
is really cool.
And finally, recipes, of
course.  Which we saw with
Rakuten in the beginning.  So,
how do you get all of these rich
results?  Well, Mariya mentioned
that briefly.
Essentially, it's just a bunch
of JSON LD mark-up that you can
add to top of your pages that
gives us a lot more information.
So this is something that you
can just add to the pages here.
It's really easy to add.  We
have a bunch of different types
of mark-up that you can add
here.
There's a code lab here for I/O
as well, so if you're curious on
how to do
that, I'd definitely take a look
at the code lab.  I have a link
here.  The code lab includes
information on finding the right
types of mark-up to add, how to
add it, and how the test it.  So
that's a great thing to check
out.
Another element when it comes to
web pages, if you're working on
just a general web page project,
is speed.  For us, speed is a
ranking factor at Google, so it
helps us to determine
which pages we should show in
the order, in the search
results.  But generally, we've
also found that speed makes a
big difference, even outside of
search engines.  And there are
various tools to test speed.
We have a link here that gives
you an overview of the different
testing tools that we have.
One of the tools is page speed
insights that gives you a great
overview of what you could be
testing, what you could be
looking at, what you could be
improving.
And then one other really
important tool when it comes to
Search is Search Console, kind
of what the name says.
So within Search Console, you
get a lot of information about
this whole pipeline that Mariya
showed, everything
from discovery to crawling to
indexing, and to serving.  How
we show your pages in the search
results, you can find
information about
this in Search Console.
Additionally, we'll alert you
of critical issues as they
arise.  So we strongly recommend
that everyone checks this out if
you're making a public web
presence, anything that you
want to have indexed in Search,
and it looks like a lot of you
do.
So the first step when it
comes to Search Console is to
verify ownership.  We don't show
the data in Search Console to
just everyone.  You have to kind
of prove to us that this is
actually your website.
One thing that I find really
important here is if you're
making a project for others
online, make it as easy as
possible for them to verify
ownership.  So make it possible
for them to add any of these
verification tokens so that they
don't always have to come back
to the development team and say,
hey, I need this special file
that has this
content and put that on the page
.
So we talked about websites
quite a
bit, but web app is another
really important topic, which I
imagine a lot of you have seen
in different ways here at I/O
already.  Web app is kind of
like a normal website, but it
provides a lot more
interactive functionality,
interaction, maybe logged in
view, personalization.  Maybe it
has parts that don't actually
need to be indexed as well.  For
example, a travel business might
have information about
timetables and general pricing,
but also have detailed
information about kind of
specific connection plan for
individual connections or
personalized pricing as well.
Or, in this case, for Search
Console, we have a lot of
general informational pages, as
well as a lot of content that's
kind of unique and where you
have to be logged in to actually
gain access to that.
So for these type of sites,
you kind of have to balance
between what you want to have
indexed and what you don't
really want to have indexed.
And for web apps in general,
I also take a look at the java
script side
session from earlier today
.
There are a few things we
found that are kind of unique
when it comes to web apps that
generally don't play such a big
role on websites in general,
especially if you're making
normal HTML pages.
The first one is how to actually
find URLs on your site.  So we
talked about URLs briefly.
Mariya mentioned how important
they are for discovering pages,
and within web apps, we've seen
that people sometimes don't use
traditional anchor tags to let
us know about URLs.  So, in
particular, we love finding
things like this, where we've
had an A tag, a link to a page.
We control that.  It's really
easy to find.  It's a lot
trickier when you have
something like a span that calls
a java script function with an
on click handler.  Then search
engines, when they look at that,
they're like, I don't know, what
do we need to do here?  Does
this show a dialogue?  Does this
show new page?  Does this go
somewhere?  We don't know.  So
we can't crawl this kind of
link.
So what you can do, if you
want to have an on-click handler
and handle
things in java script is combine
the two.
So you have your on-click
handler and your attribute to
let us know about the other page
that we can go off and crawl.
And another extreme when we come
to web apps is we often run into
situations where we see tons of
different URLs, which makes it,
again, quite inefficient to
actually crawl through.  So,
there are different things that
you can do here to let us know
about this.  The first is
obviously to avoid us actually
going off and crawling all of
these different URLs.  So if
these don't provide unique
functionality that you need to
have indexed separately, maybe
you can use other ways of
linking to them other than A
element.
Another thing that you can do is
within search consoleSearch
Console, tell us about
individual parameters within the
URL that you don't care about.
So this is a really neat tool,
but it's also very strong
functionality, in that if you
set this up indirectly, then of
course we won't go off and crawl
all of these URLs.  And if this
is something that you care
about, then absolutely we won't
be able to index that.
So watch out for this, but
this is a great way of handling
this kind of duplication within
a website.
Again, like we talked about
before, a lot of web apps use
java script frameworks, and you
have to watch out
for some specific details as
well.  We can crawl and index
the content in an efficient way.
For that, I really refer back to
the java script side session
that we had this morning.  A
really quick way, if you just
want
to have a short view of whether
or not your java script site,
your web app
works for Search is to use a
mobile-friendly test, which is
shown here, which shows the
mobile view as mobile Google bot
would show.  This is really
important for us,
because we're switching to
mobile first indexing, where
Google bot is actually using a
mobile device to crawl pages
rather than a desktop device.
So definitely makes sense to
check this out.
We also have a bunch of best
practices and general guidelines
that apply more to web apps that
you can check out in the other
sessions as well.
So, what do you do if you're
not just building one
application or one website, but
rather a whole platform?  I
don't know.  Mariya?  Can you
tell us more?
>> MARIYA MOEVA: I have some
ideas
.  You could be building an
individual
site or a web app for yourself
or someone else.  Or you could
be contributing to the entire
management system or another
hosting platform.  And here,
what I mean by in is, any type
of platform where other people
can create their own online
presence.  So, it can come in
different flavors.  For example,
it could be something like Word
Press where you could download
it and host it on your open
server, or it could be a fully
hosted system plus your own
domain, like Square Space, for
example, or it could be
something where you just get a
URL on their own domain,
and also it's hosted by them
like Tumblr.  So there are all
these different flavors that you
could be working for a system
like this, which in its own turn
has a bunch of users.  So what
you do affects all of these
people, and that is a lot of
power, and a lot of
responsibility.
So we're going to talk about
what can you do to make all
these people successful in
search by making some changes to
the platform itself.
And this is a really important
topic
for us right now, because more
than 50% and growing of the web
is currently built on various
TMSs.  So, more than half of the
content on the web is affected
by the systems, and if you're
working in one of them or
planning to do so in the future,
it's
really great if you're able to
make people successful as well,
because
that's why they came on the
ebbhe web, maybe connect to some
customers and so forth.
So we've been thinking a lot
about this, and we've built a
set of APIs to help you
integrate search functionality
directly into the interface of
those systems.  And I want to
show you some APIs and how
they've been integrated already,
maybe to give you some
inspiration and ideas about what
you can do.
So, as John was mentioning
before,
the first thing that we need in
order to show any type of Search
information or Search
functionality is to have proof
that you're indeed the owner of
the site.  He mentioned how this
works for individual sites, so
you can have an hl file, you can
have a DNS entry, so forth.  But
for the less savvy CMS users,
wouldn't it be great if you
could actuallyHTML file, you can
have a DNS entry, so forth.  But
for the less savvy CMS users,
wouldn't it be great if you
could actually simplify it to
one click?  And it is possible
with the verification API.  So
we've built this API so that you
can use it, and if the user
authorizes you, you could verify
their site, which is hosted on
your platform on their
behalf.  They just need to click
one button and they immediately
have access to the search
information, so the experience
for them is really smooth and
you can do this for a thousand
users or two million users or
whatever it is, and immediately
they get access to all kind of
interesting stats.
Which brings me to the next API,
which is the Search Console API,
and that provides access to
aggregated steps per site.  So
you can see things like clicks,
impressions, crawlers.  You can
submit a site map through there.
And you can slice and dice this
in many different ways.
So, for example, you can look
per country, per time period, or
per dwishgs and you can build
very interesting interfaces with
that.  And here on the slide is
an example of
a request where you just pull in
the top queries per clicks for a
specific period
of time, and as a result, you
can get the queries position and
so forth.
Now, a table in itself might
be
informative, but it's not
really exciting.
We've been working with WIX, and
they created this achievements
side bar for their users.
So they're using the search
analytics data to give these
little passages every time
something happens that they
think
the user will be happy to hear
about.  So their users are super
excited about
this gamefied approach, and
they're constantly looking to
see, okay what did I get now?
Here's clicks and impressions
built in an achievement side bar
like this.
We've also been working with
Square Space, and actually just
this Monday, they announced this
new report that they integrated
into the interface of their own
CMS.  So what you see here is
the one-click verification.
When the user clicks connect to
Google, on the back end, their
site gets verified, and then
this report gets populated with
information from Search Console.
So here, the user can see
clicks, impressions, and the
time series over the last month.
Square Space has a bunch of
other analytics reports inside
their CMS, so people can compare
and build the full picture of
how they're doing in search.
And at this point, they don't
even
know that Search Console exists,
but they have everything that
they need to know how they're
doing and to accomplish the
correct tasks right there in
their Square Space dashboard.
So we are pretty excited
about this kind of functionality
and we want to build up on it,
and we would be looking forward
to work with other CMSs, if
you're representing one and
you're interested in this.
Another thing that we really
wanted
to help users with is get their
content as fast as possible on
the search results.  And so
we've been looking into ways to
use the indexing API that we
have in order to get content
submitted super quickly, and
then also be able to share the
indexing decisions.  So what did
our search systems think about
this URL and what did they want
to do with it.  And we worked on
this for a few months, and at
this point, it's in a place
where this can happen within
seconds.
So, again, with WIX, we built a
pretty cool integration, where
when the user submits a page and
it matches a certain quality
criteria, basically, they can
click a button within the WIX
interface, and then the page
gets submitted through the
indexing API, and then after
that, they immediately get a
response if their page got on
the search results or not.
So for the WIX users, this is a
pretty cool experience because
they can see their page in the
search results immediately after
they've created it.  There's no
waiting, there's no wondering,
am I on Search or not?  Within
seconds, they're in Google.
So, we're interested in
working with other CMSs, and if
you represent some kind of
content management system or a
platform, which lets users
create their
own presence online, and
especially if your users are
less savvy and they don't really
know what to do with Search, we
are really interested in talking
to you to see if it might be a
good fit to participate in the
CMS partnership program.
So there's a link on this slide
which will take you to a forum,
and there you can tell us a
little bit more about who you
represent and how you would like
to work with us.
So, looking forward to hearing
from some of you, hopefully.
Now, you could be
contributing not just to the
core product of the CMS, but to
a bunch of other things which
people install in order to
enhance the
functionality of their site
.  One of those things are
plugins.  So, for example,
things like a shopping cart or
maybe a way to add reviews or a
comment plugin, things like
that.  So, while it can enhance
the functionality of the site,
it can also significantly alter
the functionality of the site in
terms of performance and other
factors.
So, I wanted to give you a
few tips
on what to do if you're building
plugins.
First of all, make sure that it
doesn't slow down the
performance of the site.
So in order to do this, have a
test site, install a plugin, and
use our
speed tools to make sure that
the site with the plugin is
doing just as well as the site
without the plugin.
This is webpagetest.org, and the
neat part about it is that
it will give you a super
detailed breakdown of what and
when.  So you can see how your
plugin is affecting the
performance of the site.  So
test that out.
Then, if you're building a
common plugin, and if you've
been on the Internet in general,
you will know that there are a
lot of comments out there, which
are maybe a lot less valuable
than other comments.  And
especially in some spaces,
they're altogether spammy, or
they're bots which are going
around and posting autogenerated
stuff in order to create links
that they're hoping search
engines will follow to some
spammy websites.
So this is not pleasant for any
user.  And you can actually help
them out a little bit if you're
building a plugin
like this by adding a specific
type of
annotation to those links by
default so that search engines
know not to trust them.  This is
a link attribute that we call No
Follow, and basically what it
does is it will just tell search
engines, don't follow this link.
Don't trust it.  So if you're
building a comment plugin,
definitely consider adding this
to the links in the comments.
Finally, and most
unfortunately, we have noticed
that one of the main
vectors for attack on websites,
and attacks on websites are
increasing, is hacks through
plugins.  So a lot of hackers
and malicious -- other malicious
people will get access to a site
through an old plugin, and if
you're building plugins, there's
a few things you can do to make
sure that your users are not
affected by this.
First of all, make sure that
every time you add an update,
everybody who has this plugin
automatically receives it.
Then, make sure to follow coding
best practices so that there's
no back door so that the hackers
can exploit.  And finally, if
you get tired of this plugin and
decide not to support it
anymore, make sure it is clear
to people that this is not
supported so they don't
go ahead and install something
that is actually making their
site more vulnerable.
These are another thing that
is very closely related to CMSs,
and a lot of people install them
in order to improve the
appearance of their site to make
it look cooler, or give it a
specific feel.  So they can
change how the site looks and
how users perceive it, but they
can also affect performance and
they can also affect mobile
friendliness.
So, again here, test your theme,
make sure that it's responsive.
You can do this with a
mobile-friendly test that John
was showing earlier.  And for
performance specifically, we
recommend, again, having a test
site with the theme, and with
another theme, having a look at
how it performs.
Lighthouse is one of our speed
tools that's really useful in
this case, because it's in the
browser.  You don't need to have
the site processed by Search in
order to test it.
So here's a blogger site that we
used for the purposes of this
example.  We installed the
theme, and then we
used lighthouse to do the
performance testing.  So you see
how long it takes actually
until what they called the first
meaningful page, which is when
all the elements appear to the
user.
So the overall score for this
team was not super great, and
the specific user metrics were
not great either.  But then we
went ahead and we switched to
another theme.  So you can see
here, it's much faster to load,
and the user can interact with
it much faster as well, and
consequentially, the score is
also great.
So if you're building themes,
definitely make sure that it's
performance and also it's
responsive by using the free
tools that we provide.
Hopefully, for any of these
things that we've told you you
might be building, you might
have enough tools and equipment
to go ahead and make
improvements and make your users
happy and more successful in
search.  We know that there's
many, many different details and
links that we provided.
So if you have to remember just
four things, pay attention to
what John is going to tell you
right now.
>> JOHN MUELLER: All right.
Thanks.  Wow, that was a lot.
Looking back at these things,
there are a few common elements
that we
covered that came up again and
again.  So first, is remember
the basics.  URLs, titles, and
descriptions.  They do matter.
They do play a big role when it
comes to search.  They play a
big role in how people come to
your site through search.
Secondly, remember to take
advantage of structure data,
like the Rakuten example in the
beginning.  Obviously, they saw
a big change in the traffic from
Search, even without ranking
changes, just by making their
Search results look a lot more
visually appealing.
And then, take advantage of
all of the tools and APIs that
we have available.
So use Search Console,
understand how Search Console
works, use the APIs from Search
Console to make it better for
your users, people who are using
your products to really create
fantastic web presences.
And then, finally, especially if
you're making something for
other people
to create web presences in, make
it as easy as possible for them
to do the right thing as well.
So, make it easy for them to put
the
right fields in, to add data
about titles and descriptions on
pages, make it easy for them to
really create high performance
web pages.
So, these are only some general
tips, I think to get started
with.  There are obviously a lot
of different aspects that come
into play with search, but we
think these aspects are really
critical to start with.  We have
a lot more information in our
developer center, developer
guides.
We have Search Console help
center with a lot more
information about Search in
general, and specifically about
Search Console.
If you have any more
questions today,
we'll be in the Web and Sandbox
area later today, so feel free
to come by there as well.
And finally, there are, of
course, other ways to reach out
to us online as well.  You can
find us on Twitter.  We do live
office hours hangouts where
you can join us with a YouTube
Live hangout.  We're available
in the webmaster help forum if
you have any questions.
So, don't let questions kind of
stick around, make sure you get
answers to them from us if you
need them.
We hope you found this
introduction into Search
interesting.  Thank you all for
coming.
We wish you and your projects
more success online through
Google Search.  Thank you.
[Applause]
On
May 10, 2018.
Creating a Persona.
Realtime captioning on this
screen.
>> Welcome. Please fill in
the seats near the front of the
room.  Thank you.
Creating a Persona.
>> At this time please find
your seat.  Our session will
begin soon.
S
Had.
(applause).
>> I always wanted to do that
little hop up the stairs.
Thank you for coming, we've got
the coolest people at IO right
here.
(applause).
Give yourselves a hand!
Excellent.  Excellent.  Thank
you for joining me, we're going
to dig into the world of
persona.  First I want to see a
show of hands, how many people
brought a persona with them
today?
>> WALLY BRILL: Great. It's
a trick question.  You all did.
Oh, I better get the clicker.
So we're going to talk about
how persona can make your
actions stand out,
they can extend the brand, and
they can increase usability.
First, I'm Wally Brill.  I'm the
head of conversation disierntion
advocacy and education here at
Google, and I've been teaching
robots to talk for about 20
years.  Actually I've been
teaching them to talk longer
than that, but when I was a kid,
they didn't talk back, which was
kind of depressing.
So this is a previous Persian
that of mine, I even had hair.
I just want to tell you folks,
there
is no distinct correlation
between hair
loss and designing personas,
it's okay.
Years ago when I had hair, I was
a record producer, I was working
mostly in the UK.
And I had this idea, whether
it was good or not, I'm not
sure, but I wanted
to create an opera that was
interactive, I wanted to be able
to talk to the cargts and change
plots, like one of those choose
your own adventure stories,
right?
So what did I do?
I decided I would find a
technology that would work to do
this, and in those days we were
thinking about things like
CD-ROMs, I don't know if any of
you remember CD-ROMs.
Oh, I see a nod.  I see a couple
nods.  Good.  Whew.
I went to the company that
invented speech recognition and
said to them can you tell me
about this stuff?  They said
well you know about sound,
dmom here, and they made me take
a job
there and they sent me to see a
man named James Giancola, I
don't know if you know of him,
he was one of the pioneers for
conversational design for
interactive speech, he gave a
talk at Stanford which
completely blew my mind because
it was about how you can speak
naturally to a robot and it will
speak naturally back to you.
He wrote a book called Voice
User Interface Design which I
recommend to anybody interested
in this stuff.
Moving along, this is our
fabulous conversation design
team that I recently joined at
Google.
Lots of happy faces there.
Now, let's get down to it.
What's a persona, how do we go
about designing the perfect
digital employee that's going to
work for us and make us stand
out?
So what is a persona?
It's the aspect of someone's
character
that's presented or perceived by
others, it's your face that you
show to the world, it's the who
of who you are that you let
people see, right?
Now, in acting, people use
personas all the time.
In the 1930s, Leslie Howard and
Norman Shirer did a version of
Romeo and Juliet that was very
successful, it was very widely
liked and it did well.
Now, spin onto the 1990s, and
here is
Leonardo DiCaprio and clairl
Danes performing exactly the
same content but with very
different personas and it came
across very much for
contemporary and it was a big
success of the time but very,
very different from that
original film.
Now, everybody has a unique
persona, you get it when you
born, it changes with you as you
develop and as you grow, and
like I say, it's the who of who
you
are, it differentiates us one
from another and makes us
individuals.
But now we live in the future,
right?  There are 500 million
devices that
have the Google Assistant on
them, 500 million.  Can I get an
okay?
(Cheering) right.  That's a
lot of people, a lot of devices
too.
So people have high expectations
of what an intelligent assistant
can do and how and where we can
interact with it, and it's not
just this thing that you talk
to.  Now we're talking about
surfaces that
the AI moves across,
effortlessly, from
your Google Home to your TV to
your smartphone to your car to
your watch,
all these surfaces we have to
take into consideration when
we're designing persona.  See,
it's not just voice, it's also
audio content like sound design,
it's
visual content now, it's
interaction design.  The
interaction design actually has
a
lot to do with how your persona
comes
across, and it's even
typography.
Here is a quick example.
This is a joke, I am not holding
up
any hope for it being a great
joke, but you can see that the
punchline is really
punched up because of
typography.  So we've got to
think about visual
surfaces as well as audio
situations.
So let's pivot for a second, and
now talk about a voice-first
world and
understand why persona design is
so important.
So we're going on to talk about
a series of documents that you
will make when you're designing
a persona and what they'll do is
they'll help you keep the
writing, the things that the
system says consistent and clear
because otherwise it can appear
fractured, and if the persona is
fractured, people lose trust in
the actual action.
So in wired for speech -- well,
sorry,
there is no such thing as no
persona, by the way, that was my
trick question I stuck in there.
There we go.
In wired for speech,  Cliff Nass
and Scott Brave said when people
hear any voice, they
automatically and
unconsciously assign a
personality to it.  This is a
really important thing.  Within
a second, second and a half of
hearing a voice, you create an
image in your mind, you have an
idea of who you're listening to.
You know what I mean?
So whenever you hear somebody,
somebody calls you up that you
don't know, you've got an idea
of who they are, you have a
sense of them because
you know what, we can infer age,
we can
infer gender, we understand
their educational level by the
kind of things
they say, we get register.  Now,
register is the social context,
it's where this persona is in
relation to me.  Is it my boss?
Is it my employee?  Is it my
peer?  Who is this that I'm
speaking with?  We also get a
sense of locale if they have an
accent that's different from
ours.  We just don't recognize
accents if we have the same one.
So the other inferred traits
we get
are intelligence,
trustworthiness and likeability.
All these things come through in
that first second, second and a
half of hearing a voice.  So
it's really important that we
get this right.
We have to set ourselves up for
success because now more than
ever the
experience of the action is the
brand to the consumer.
What happens is every touch
point matters.
So billboard advertising, the
web,
radio, TV, absolutely -- social
media,
absolutely every touch point
carries the brand essence, so
it's vital that we get
it right because if we leave it
to chance, you never know what
you're going to get, so you
don't just use anything.  You've
got to design your persona
because otherwise the results
will be  unpredictable.
So how do we do it?  How do
we actually design one?  This is
where some of the fun stuff
starts.
We need to make that digital
employee, and what I have done
is I've suggested
we take two airlines to map this
out and to talk about how we do
it.  These are two airlines that
obviously don't exist.  One is
Important  Airlines, it's a
national carrier, it's
important, you
can see their strap line:  We're
important and we will get you
there.  Right?  Kind of
traditional tion kind of
straight.
On the other hand, there's
Millennial Airlines and their
strap line is:  It's an awesome
day to fly!  Do you want to say
that with me?  It's an awesome
day to fly!  Once more, with
feeling.  It's an awesome day to
fly!  Great.  Thank you.  Whew.
So the first step in
designing a
persona is we need to understand
the brand.  We need to interview
the stakeholders, we need to
talk to people in brand, in
marketing, in customer
experience,
customer service.  We want to
look to see if there's a style
guide.  Now, the marketing
people and the brand people will
have already done this, they
will have distilled their brand
down, but you want to go over it
and understand it and really get
it.
So you're going to experience
the product too.  You're going
to get on the plane and go take
a trip somewhere.  You may visit
the contact center
because those contact center
agents are actually carrying the
brand essence with them when
they speak to customers over the
phone.  You're going to check
out social  media, and if
there's a retail
component, you'll go into a
store, right?
So let's talk about Important
for a second.  Let's talk about
my water for a second.  Here it
is.
So Important Airlines brand is
solid.  They're confident.
They're experts.  They know what
they're doing.  They're
reliable.  They're utterly
straightforward.  There's no
frills or anything.  And they're
safe.  They've got a great
safety record.  But you're not
going to get wildly excited
flying on Important, right?  No
surprises.
Now, Millennial, on the other
hand, where it's an awesome day
to fly, thank you for helping me
with that, the Millennial
Airlines brand is bold, it's
hip, it's fun, it's friendly,
it's even exciting and
delightful, it's a whole
different kind of world.  It's
there to bring excitement of
travel into your life.
So those are two sets of
brand essences, right?  Now
let's understand the customer.
We need to know who is going to
use this interaction.  So we
want to understand their context
and their customer journey.  We
want to know who they are
through their demographics,
where do they live, what do they
like, how old are they, we want
to understand the frequency of
engagement because that's going
to have a lot to do with how
verbose your
prompts are.
If they're freblght users, you
can keep things short F they're
infrequent users, you might want
to give them a little more
information, and we want to
understand their expectations
and needs.  Now, one thing you
should know is that
people generally like to be
mirrored.  They like the idea of
interacting with someone who at
least relates to them in
some ways.  It's a preference,
right?
So the Important Airlines
customer, mid 30s and up.  These
are business travelers, they're
frequent, frequent fliers,
they're road warriors, they're
high value because those
business class and first class
seats are expensive
.  Whereas on the other hand,
our millennial customer is late
teens on mid 30s, they're
millennials, they're holiday
makers, they're backpackers,
they're Young families going to
Orlando maybe, they're
budget-conscious and they don't
use the airm very much, they
uses it for holidays once or
twice -- and they don't use the
airline very much, they use it
for holidays once or twice a
year.
So we know the brand, we know
the customer.  Now, what task
are we going to do here?
What am I've chosen is FliFlo,
flight information, status of my
flight, is it late, cancelled,
on time, when is it expected,
all that good stuff, right?
Which leads us to choosing
the medium for the audio.  Now,
there are two ways to do this.
You can use text-to-speech, TTS,
I'm
sure you all know what that is,
versus custom recording, which
is when you have an actor in
front of a microphone recording
prompts.  Right?  Text-to-speech
is the computer-generated voice.
Customer recording is the human
actor.
So text-to-speech is infinitely
scalable, it's really easy to
use, it's really cheap, because
what it's doing is it's reading
written content.  It handles
dynamic content really well, so
in our case, we've got an
airline with a lot of changes
going on,
you know,
Duluth to Minneapolis, all these
things going ask stuff change p
on the fly so we'll probably use
text-to-speech there.
Oh, can you go back one, please?
There we go.
The cons are limited voice
availability and occasionally
you'll hear, I think Sundar
mentioned this in
the keynote, you hear procity,
and that's the melody of speech,
and occasionally, certainly in
the old days, text-to-speech
procity wasn't great.  I think
you'll agree from what we heard
this week that it's now
phenomenally good, it's almost
indistinguishable from human
speech.
So TimeOut Magazine?
in London decided to use
text-to-speech, happenings
happening.  From secret Tango
lessons to breakfast
raves, connecting customers to
the coolest stuff to do, they
do.
They created tirks o who is a
millenial, she's hip and
happening, she knows what's
going on in London at any given
time.
Let me give an example of
what she sounds like.
>> Okay, Google, talk to Time
Out.
>> Hey, you again. Got a quiet
week ahead?  Not anymore.  When
do you want to go out?  Today,
this week or this weekend?
>> Who are you?
>> I'm Tio. No one knows the
city like me because I've been
discovering the brilliant and
searching out the secret and
extraordinary for a long time.
If you want to know about food,
art, culture and nightlife, then
I am your social companion.  Try
me.  What do you want to do and
when do you want to do it?
>> Where are you from?
>> In West Kensington born and
raised.  On the estate was where
I spent most of my days.
Chilling out maximum I know
can, relax Illinois n, all
hipster.  Skating so much.
I got into debt and my mom
started to shout.  She said you
need to get a job at a place
called Time Out.  What else do
you want to do?
>> Quit.
>> WALLY BRILL: That's pretty
cool, right?  Pretty
interesting.
That's a pretty solid persona
and you get a sense of who she
really is.
Now, on the custom recording
side, headspace, which does
meditation
guidance, needed to use an
actual real
voice Andy  Puticom who is the
guy who started headspace and he
does guided meditations and I
won't play one now because they
chill me out so much I couldn't
carry on with this talk, but
they're really, really good.
And the thing about custom
recording
is it's natural, it's
expressive, it's comprehensible
and any voice in the world can
be used, right?  You can go and
hire anybody to be the voice
actor.  Now, luckily for
Headspace they've got Andy, he's
there all the time, because
sometimes it can be expensive to
record and maintain, and it
relies on the
availability of that artist.
Andy goes there every day, so
he's okay.
So let me play you an example of
Headspace just a short one to
hear what the voice sounds like.
>> Hi. My name is Andy.
Welcome to headspace.
Using proven meditation and
mindful nsz tech niksz, I'll
show you how to train your mind
for a healthier, happier, more
enjoyable life.  To get started,
try one of our short sessions,
they're each under two minutes
long and can help bring a little
more mindfulness into your life.
Three options to choose from,
wake up, take a moment or
unwind.
Which one would you like to try?
>> WALLY BRILL: Okay. Now,
because we're doing flight
information, we've chosen TTS,
right?
So the fun part, how do we
design this persona?  How do we
create that perfect
representative, our digital
employee?  What are the steps we
have to take?  This is where we
get creative, dig into that
creative brain and let's get
going.  So we go back to the
airlines.  We understand the
brand, the customer, the task
and the medium.  Now we're going
to go and invent some people.
We're going to write biographies
for imaginary characters who
might be a good fit for the job
we have for them.
So who is that perfect
representative?  Who can it be?
They've got to make the action
useful and usable.  They've got
to be comprehensible.  They've
got to be somebody that you
would really want to work with.
The first step is register.  We
need to know what that social
context is.  Right?  We talked
about this a little bit before.
What's the relationship between
me and that persona?  Is it my
peer, a really close friend of
mine?  Is it an employee,
somebody that works for me and
just does whatever I ask
whenever I need it?  Or is it an
advisor, somebody who
maybe knows more stuff than me,
is at somewhat of a higher
explefl that I'm taking
information from?
Now, when we do this for real,
you'll probably want to create
three different
personas, and you may make them
of three different registers,
someone a peer,
maybe two are employees, you'll
play around with it a little
built, and you'll make the
registry different for them.
Now, have a look at this chart.
This again comes from Clifford
Nass and you'll see that there's
a vertical axis which is
dominance and submissiveness
versus friendliness and
distance.  This is kind of handy
because when you're deciding
what kind of persona you want
and how it's going to relate to
your customer, you can use this
quite
effectively to position them.
Now, for Important Airlines, we
decided we wanted a
butler, somebody like a butler
who would relate to that
demographically wefl, remember
they're 35 and up, we
wanted somebody with some
gravitas,
it's a British airline h British
airline, so we wanted a sort of
concierge character that you
could trust.
So we have Terrence Butler, he's
56, his occupation is Butler.
He comes from Bromley in Kent,
which is a lovely suburb.  Why
do I care about his height and
weight?  Because it affect
voice.  It affects the largeness
of the voice,
versus the smallness of the
voice
(Talking low, then higher) so
there's a lot in there in terms
of size.
It he's firmly built, thinning
hair, just a shout out to people
losing their hair.  He lives
where he works, he's single, and
he went to the Ivor Spencer
international school for Butler
administrators, which is a real
place!  Can you believe  it?
Phenomenal.  Am.
Carrying on, he's a collector
of rare wines.  Why do we will
care?  Because he's detail
oriented.
His parents, Jack, was a retired
hotel
manager, so he understands the
hospitality  industry.  Right?
His mother was a retired nurse.
Again, a caretaking profession.
He doesn't have any siblings.
The reason we're interested in
siblings is if you're the oldest
of four  kids, you may be a
little better at being a
caretaker than the youngest, and
my family actually works that
wairks I'm the youngest and I'm
a little crazy but
my eldest brother is very
straight-ahead.  What does he
like to wawfn?
He likes to watch  Upstairs
Downstairs, downtown Abby, he
has also been 30 years in this
job, so he really knows it.
Now we flashback to the brand
attributes of Important and see
how they match up.
So Important is solid, it's
confident, it's expert, it's
reliable, it's straightforward,
it's safe.  Right?
So how does Terrence relate to
that?
Well, he's a butler, he's been a
butler for a long time, he's
confident, expert and reliable,
he's very straightforward, and
he's worked for that family for
over 30 years, so he's somebody
you can trust, and the fact
that eases an avid collector of
rare wines tells you that he is
detail oriented and he is an
expert.
Now, the next step is we're
going to create beyond this
birks o, we're going to create
two more documents.  We're going
to create a monologue, which
gives us a sense of who this
character is.  It's a paragraph
like a conversation that they're
having with a friend in a bar or
somewhere where they're just
telling them something that
happened
that day or that week, and it's
really
just to get us into the
character a
little more deeply, and if
you're using custom recording
with voices actors, it's a great
way for them to dive back into
the character if they've
recorded
that monologue once because on
Monday
they may be in the studio
recording for
a sausage company, and on
Tuesday they may be doing a car
commercial.  But on Thursday
they're coming in to do your
action, and you want them to be
in your persona.  So that's why
these materials really help.
The monologue really helps.
So let me give you example of
one.
>> I quite enjoy this
occupation.  It's extremely
gratifying to know that one is
indispensable.
If sir is stepping out of an
evening, I shall have prepared
sir's dinner jablght and
accessories and I shall of
course assist him in tying his
bow  tie.  The work of a
gentleman's gentleman is never
done.
>> WALLY BRILL: So he's pretty
formal, right?
His language is pretty formal.
And the next thing we're
going to do is we're going to
create a sample dialogue.
Now, I know that all of you
whenever you decide to make an
action or create
an action, you start with
conversation, you start with
sample dialogues, right?  You
write the conversation out like
a
two-part play, here is the user,
here is the system, here is the
user, here is the system, and
that really helps to
tell you whether this
conversation is
natural-sounding.
So here is Terrence in an
actual interaction the way he
would be if he
were working in the action.
>> Okay, Google, talk to
Important Airlines.
>> Getting Important Airlines.
>> Good morning. You're
through to Important Airlines,
am I speaking with Wally?
>> That's right.
>> Thank you. And do you
require information regarding
your flight to London today?
>> Yes.
>> WALLY BRILL: So and do
you require information
regarding your flight to London
today?  Very formal language.
Vesm in persona.  Very much
locked into what we would
expect for this character.
Now let's move along and go
to Millennial, which is, as we
know, a very different airline
indeed.
So the Millennial  Airlines
persona is a Young woman we call
Helen Highwater.  I'll say that
again.  Helen Highwater.
She's 26 years old, she's a gate
agent at San Francisco
International, she comes from
Mill  Valley, California,
another nice suburb, she's 5-5,
115 pounds, physical descripg
shows she's
kind of a hipster, she has this
wild asymmetrical haircut, she
lives in a 3 bedroom apartment
in the Mission with a
couple friends of hers, Jack who
is a software developer
interestingly enough and Natalie
in med school.  She's going out
with Gary, who is a
drummer in a band call the
Ironic  Three.  The reason
they're ironic is because there
are five members.  She studied
drama and English, which gives
her a lot of help towards what
she really wants to be, which is
a standup comic.  That's her
dream of the she spends every
free minute working on her act.
So her parents, Ron, manages
Mill
Valley branch of the Bank of
Marin, so she has a certain
sense of responsibility.
Lucy teaches English Lit at the
middle school, a love of
language.  You may think some of
these things aren't that
necessary, but I promise you, if
you are get into a studio with a
voice arltist, they're going to
go thank you, thank you, thank
you, thank you, this gives me
some depth, it gives me
something to work with.  She
doesn't have any siblings.
Had he work history was that
she -- her work history was that
she was a bartender at Cobbs
comedy club.
She likes Game of Thrones,
Stranger
things, Amie  Sadaris, Amie
Shipper, all the good stuff.
Now, back to the brand.  This
brand is bold, hip, fun,
happening, they're friendly,
they're exciting, and they're
delightful.  I think she could
be a really good match for this.
So let's see how she ties up
for it.  26-year-old hipster.
She's hip.  She works as a gate
agent at San Francisco
International, she's done it for
three years without missing a
day.  She's reliable.  We can
count on her.  She's a people
person, she gets along with
everybody, even drummers.  That
makes her friendly and fun.  And
her dream is to make a living as
a standup.  Now, if you're going
to be a standup, you better be
bold, you better be friendly,
you better be fun, and please be
delightful.
So she's got a monologue.
Let's have a listen.  Zie use
everything, and believe me, when
you deal with the passengers,
there's endless amounts of
material like the woman who was
going to loss stone but her
luggage was on Italy way to aws
stirntion or the parents off on
holiday who each expect the
other one to Brit kids to the
airport.  Then there's the guy
who thinks he deserves an
upgrade because he was in some
obscure rock band from 20 years
ago or something.  It's great
training for a standup and I get
paid for it.  And if I can deal
with them, there isn't a heckler
in the world who can bother me.
>> WALLY BRILL: So pretty
consistent, she is who she is,
we get a sense of her through
the monologue.  Now let's see
what she would be like
in a sample die dialogue,
actually doing the job.
>> Okay, Google, talk to Millal
Airlines.
>> Getting Millal Airlines.
(Tone).
>> Millennial Airlines, it's an
awesome day to fly.  Is this
Wally?
>> Yup.
>> Great. Document info about
your flight to London today?
>> That's right.
>> WALLY BRILL: So
completely different kind of
language.  Do you want info?
It's an awesome day to fly.
Very different than our last
persona,
Terrence, because these brands
are so dispircht we need to be
consistent to
the brand, so as you can see, it
makes a difference.
Right snt.
So in terms of positioning
these guys, where do we think
they would fit on this chart?
Well, let's start with Terrence.
He's kind of submissive, he's
introverted, he just does what
he's
told, he does the job, he does
it very, very well, but does he
the job.  He's not overly
friendly, he's not distant, he's
just kind of in that
middle place somewhere.  What
about Helen?  She's super
friendly, she's an
extrovert to the extreme and
she's a lot of fun, so she
belongs right there over on the
right.  The next step which
we're not going to
dive into too deem right now is
what we call user testing,
sometimes you do what's called
Wizard of Oz testing, you can do
this effectively with dialogue
flow by actually mocking up
quickly the main pass of your
interactions and then
playing them for people, have
people work through them and get
a sense of how
usable it is, and how much that
persona
matches their ingoing
expectations.
So we've got a few take-aways
for you.
First, review the actions you've
already made.  And they're
wonderful.  I know.  But is the
persona clearly defined?  Do you
feel confident that the persona
is well imagined and well
created?  Is it representative
of the brand, the user and the
task?
Does it work right?
Number two, define that
persona.
You're going on follow the
process, learn about the brand,
know the user, know the task,
and define appropriate
characters, which is for me the
fun part.
And then bring it to life.
Write these monologues, write
these sample dialogues, and make
recordings of them because you
can only tell about
conversational voice user
interface by listening to it.
If you read it on the page, it
won't have the same effect at
all, and if you've got
stakeholders that you're trying
to talk to about what you're
doing and to explain this is the
right thing, they've got to hear
it, you don't want to give them
anything with writing on it.
Just say close your eyes, listen
to this.
And then test.  Test your action
with real customers.
Locally-fidelity prototypes,
dialogue flow, however, but you
want to derive some data and
some proof points for your
stakeholders to say customers,
users
really felt this was right for
our brand.
And that gives you success, I
hope.  I'm sure.  And it will be
wonderful, and you'll make
beautiful personas.
So with that, I'm going to ask
you to give us some feedback.
You all know the drill.
And finally, here rl are a
couple rorlsz that are really
quite wonderful.  Developers.
Google.com.   Google.com/io.
Kathy Pearl who recently joined
our team wrote a wonderful book
called designing voice user
interfaces.
Wired for  Speech by Clifford
Nass I recommend, talks about
persona at great links.
And voice user interface design
by
James Giancola is a important
baseline
book, this kicked off a whole
generation of  GUI designers.
With that, thank you very,
very much
for coming, and have a wonderful
rest of IO.
(The session concluded at 3:03
p.m.)
Realtime captioning on this
screen)
screen.
Realtime captioning on this
screen
May 10, 2018.
Deploying Serverless Node.js.
Are
(Realtime captioning on this
screen)
.
Are
Deploying Serverless Node.js.
>> At this time, please find
your seat.  Our session will
begin soon.
Deploying Serverless Node.js.
>> At this time, please find
your seat.  Our session will
begin soon.
Had.
Deploying Serverless Node.js.
>> STEREN GIANNINI: Hello,
hello, welcome.
>> MYLES BORINS: Hi, everyone,
thanks for coming.
(applause).
>> MYLES BORINS: It's been a
long day, huh?  It's been a long
three days.  I know Steren and
myself really appreciate all of
you sticking around and coming
to our session, so just one more
time, thank you, everyone.
>> STEREN GIANNINI: It's good
to have you with us.
This is Myles, Myles Borins,
Myles works on Google Cloud,
we've been working together over
the last year, he
also happens to be the director
of the
nodes jis technical steering
committee.
(cheers and applause).
>> STEREN GIANNINI: And of
course,
he's a long time Node.js lover,
the first time you used Node.js
was for installation, something
like that?
>> MYLES BORINS: Yeah.
>> STEREN GIANNINI: Nice.
>> MYLES BORINS: This is
Steren, Steren is a product
manager for Google
Cloud platform, the serverless
team and we've been working
really closely on new Node.js
technologies, previously was
involved in the stack driver
error reporting product and you
used Noticed in production in
2011.  Was that like 04 or 06?
>> STEREN GIANNINI: 06 I
think.
>> MYLES BORINS: Did anyone
start
with noticed
No Dierks 06 in the awd jens?
Right on.  That was buggy, right
when they introduced util.  Fun
fact about Steren, his we go
invitation was actually written
in
JavaScript approximate, that's
still online, that means your
wedding invitation will never
break.
>> STEREN GIANNINI: Never. The
web.
All right.
So who can name this French
pastry?  So it's called a mill
fill.  Literally translating to
thousand layers.  So it's
basically a cake made of many,
many, many layered.
So one of my teachers used to
say, in French, Tout probleme
est un Mille-feuille de choses
simples.
So translating, every problem is
Mille-feuille trrks so any
problem can be broken down into
simple things.  This is true for
code and also for software
architectures.  If you break
down your big app into simple
things, it will be simpler.  If
you break them down into
Microservices.
So that brings us to
microservices.  In
Microservices?
Well, maybe your app has grown
to big,
maybe it's actually hard to
understand,
develop, maintain, manage, this
is why
Microservices can be a solution.
You break up the monolith,
decouple those Microservices,
you make them simpler to
understand and maintain, and
potentially each service will be
written in a different language
owned by a
different team and deployed
independently.
As a consequence, they'll
scale independently if you
decouple them.
The scaling is independent, too
and by making them more fine
grained, that will
result in a better utilization
of your
resources that will result in a
lower
build for you, and lastly,
Microservices
pair great with Node.js due to
the asynchronous nature of Node.
js
so Microservices, break up the
Monday list, scale independently
and pair great with Node.js.
But what is Node.js?
>> MYLES BORINS: So I was given
this slide.  Node.
js.  JavaScript.  How many
people like JavaScript?  Sweet.
So I don't know if any of you
have
seen this little emoji  list,
the rocket
turtle, sub stack drew this
turtle, JavaScript was not
supposed to be a fast language,
it was pretty amazing how fast
both as a run time and also for
node iteration.  Node is one of
those things you can get it done
in 10 or 15 minutes because
somebody has written the module,
you just need find it.
At its base, node is a
JavaScript run time, we take the
V8 virtual machine
that comes in the Chrome
browser, wrap it with an
underlying architecture
wrapping, all the system calls,
wraps platforms and allows
developers to just
write JavaScript and do compute,
write servers and all those
different things.  It allows you
to leverage your fronted end
skills, it's event driven, that
means that compute is driven by
events.  Something come putsz
when something
happens, that can be an http
request, that can be some sort
of message coming over a socket,
it can be user input with a
keyboard, it can be some sensor
if
you're work with IOT, any form
of IO.  Anytime there's input,
some sort of
compute  runs.
The event-driven architecture
plays really great with async
nonblocking I/O, multiple things
can run in parallel without
blocking each other.  When I
make some sort of request over a
socket rs I'm able to suspend,
let other things execute and
resume when I'm done without
requiring the developer to
program any of this, it just
happens.  Many events execute
without blocking each other and
this ends up being really
great for web servers because it
means multitell people can
connected can connect to the
same processor at the same time,
and it works you don't have to
worry about timing, you just
worry about handling the
evented.
So to sum that up, Node.
js is a JavaScript run time
that's event
driven with async nonblocking
I/O.
>> STEREN GIANNINI: The last
term we need to define from the
title of this talk is
serverless.
Who here is using a serverless
product?
So we should agree that there
are a lot of definitions for
server lts.  I'm going to
highlight here the key
characteristics that we'll use
around this talk.
The first one that to me is the
main characteristic is that you
pay for what
you use so it's bidding, if you
don't use it, you don't pay, and
then the bill is
proportional to your usage.  Of
course you don't need to
provision in advance any
resource, all of this is
done on demand so why are we
able to achieve that bidding
model?
Because of the rational model.
So a serverless product will
scale
with usage without having to
worry about it.  It grows with
you from a single developer to a
company with thousands of
developers.
It follows your usage.  And
why can it scale?
Well, because of a programming
model.
The Cloud providers takes care
of the rest.  You folk us on
your code.
That means that no
infrastructure management, no VM
management, everything is
abstracted from you.  So you
focus on your code, that also
means that you focus on
delivering
business value and value to your
users.
So to recap, serverless, pay for
what you use, it scales, and
allows you to focus on code.
This is the principles that we
are going to -- these are the
principles we are going to use
along that talk, and
you will see it's not actually,
not only for compute.
>> MYLES BORINS: So Google
Cloud has
a number of different serverless
offerings.  We have Cloud
functions.  How many people here
have been using node and Cloud
function so far?  Cool.
We've got
got app engine storage, Cloud
storage, Big Query, data  flow,
ML engine, Firebase sweet, app
scripts, all these different
products, what define them as
serverless is the fact that you
don't have to manage them, we'll
scale them for you, manage them
for you, you can
utilize them as much as you need
it.
>> STEREN GIANNINI: And today
we are very proud to share with
you the preview of Node.
js on the app engine standout
environment.
(cheers and applause).
Thank you.
So yes, we are adding a new
language
to app engine standout, Node.js.
We'll release it in a few weeks.
So let's see a small demo of
nodes jis on app engine
standout.  Myles will tell you
more about it.
>> MYLES BORINS: So this
package JSON file is
outpalestining a hello world
application, we have a single
start script that calls node on
server JS which if you don't
define the start
script and just run NPM start,
that's
the default command and just do,
which if you're not expecting
that to do it.  It has a single
dependency, which is express.
Here is our express app.
We're making an app using
express.  We have a single
route.
And we celebrate Node.
js on app engine standard, fall
back to 884 local development,
there's one more
thing we'll need to get this
onto app engine standard.  Tiny
bitty yaml.
This one line of yaml run time
nodejs8 is the only thing you
run on Node.
js apps and it will run dprks
the
command is gcloud app deploy.
Steren has something loaded on
his computer, so we'll switch
over to it right now.
And you're see Steren is in the
Cloud shell, he has that app we
were just showing you, and he's
going to type in
that command that I just
mentioned.
Gcloud app deploy.
So this is how you know it's a
real demo.
(laughter).
But we haven't actually deployed
yet.  Are you ready?
>> STEREN GIANNINI: Let's do
it.
>> MYLES BORINS: We're start to
go deploy.  In the time it takes
to deploy, I'll try to list all
the things I like about T it's
an idiomatic node run time
environment, meaning we're using
the exacted version of node that
gets published by Node.js, no
special run tiemgz or special
API's, it's the same app you can
run in other places, it scales
to zero so when urnltd using it,
you're not paying for T it's a
managed run time which means
everything but your code and the
node modules you're using will
get updated by us.  If there's a
security fix that needs to lan
into node, and trust me there
are, we'll patch that for you
without you or your users ever
really noticing.
Oh, wow, I couldn't even get to
to T it's already deployed.
You also get NPM on the Cloud,
hybrid monitoring for free and
free https.  Wow, that was fast.
We can go and see the service
right
now, it's already running
.  So there you go.  This
service has been deployed, we're
already running it, this is in
my opinion like a really great
user experience, being able to
deploy, have it up on the Cloud
so quickly and be able to share
that with people to take a look.
So now that we're done with
the demo,
we'll talk a little bit more.
>> STEREN GIANNINI: So this
was Node.js on app engine
standard environment.  It is
idiomatic, which means that you
can use any module from the NPM
registry that you want, there is
no A pi or
language restriction, as you've
seen, it deploys fast and scales
instantly.
And as Myles said, it is secure.
So you get one click http for
your
system domains and it
auto-updates.
So I will now do a deep dive
into
three updated piece of
infrastructure.
The first one that is what we
call internally faster than
light builds.  So what's that?
When you type gcloud app deploy,
we'll first tonal upload the
files that have actually changed
since last time.  Okay?
This is an opt myization.
The faster than light build
arrives later.  We look at your
package.JSON and package-lock.
JSON, we do NPM install for you
in the Cloud.  Good.
But actually, this is what we
defined as the speed of light.
Actually if we notice that your
package.
JSON hasn't changed, we are
going to
give you what we just gave you
before.
If you do a new deployment.
So we use our caching system to
give you the cached modules,
that's how we can go faster than
light.
This was the first piece of
updated infrastructure for this
new run time.  The second one is
a new run time environment.  So
let's see a bit of the technical
stack.
So first, you gave us your code
when you will do G Cloud at
deploy.  This is your
application code.  As I said, we
install the node modules for
you, including the native
modules, can be any modules.
And that, everybody, there is
Node.
js and here this is an off the
shelf Node.js, there's no
special customization here.
Node is relying on the OS
packages and
for example you might have heard
about headless Chrome and yes
all of the packages to run
headless Chrome are
present in the app engine image,
and
that lives on top of the regular
OS,
which is
duh but
which is Ubunt you can.  Its
automaticallily updated without
you having to worry about it.
It will automatically update
your Node.js version, the OS
package and the OS is also auto
mactdly updated.
All of that lives in the secured
sandbox, and this is a new
sandbox technology that we are
introducing with this new run
time.
Under the hood, the sandbox is
based
on Gvisor, a sandbox we opened
last week.  Check it out.
This is our new run time
environment.  And the last piece
of infrastructure I
would like to highlight is
automatic
scaling
.  What is automatic scaling?
Let's take an example.  App
engine constantly monitors the
instance capacity and traffic
that your application capacity
and traffic, and it ensures that
the appropriate number of
instances are available to run
your application.  So what does
that mean?  Let's take an
example.
So as I said, if there is no
request arrive to go your
application, there is no
instance scheduled.  And when I
say instance, it's not a VM
instance, it's an app that we
name instance.
Now some traffic toorves your
application.
Well, we will scale up as fast
as possible one instance.
Here I'm going to pause for a
second.  I want to highlight one
concept that
is very important for
developers.  The very first of
these requests will
hilt what we calling the code
start, that means that this
request will actually hit the
instance while it is
starting up and this usually
results in a higher latency than
usual.
Of course, we try to -- not
we try, but we do boot up the
instance very,
very fast, but you also have
spient a responsibility  here,
you have to ensure that your
start command is fast too.
So in the start, make sure to
not do things like build or a
lot of initialization.  Do the
minimum required to start your
application because this will
have an impact on the cold start
of your application.
So here as I said the very
first request will hit this cold
start but the next one
everything is fine.
But then your traffic will
start to
increase a little bit, and here
before this first instance
arrives at capacity, we will
anticipate that you need a
second one, and we'll schedule a
second one so that when you
actually need it, it's there.
It doesn't need to scale more.
Now let's imagine your app is
featured on a popular blog post
and you have a huge spike of
traffic.
Well, don't worry, app engine
scales very fast.  So it will be
scaleup instances as much as
needed.
You can control, you can tell us
the maximum number of instances
if that matters to you.
And of course when things go
down,
well, we will ramp down the
number of instances to zero.  So
that's what we call automatic
scaling.  You did not have to do
anything to get this behavior.
But this is not new at all.
App engine has been doing that
for ten years.  Ten years now.
What is new is that actually we
updated our automatic scaling
algorithm.  So the updates
include it is more predictable.
As a developer, you will better
understand how it behaves when
you look at your instance chart,
you will better understand it.
Second, it actually improves
instance utilization and
performance.
So we measured a reduction of
30% of those cold starts, so
that means that
the latency of all of our apps
across app engine has went down.
And also better utilization
means lower builds for everybody
using app
engine, and this was released in
the
last months.
The third point are new settings
that we are introducing to
better control
these scale algorithms, help you
balance between cost and
performance.
Also as I said, helps you cap
the number of instances so that
you can cap your build but also
the number of data connections,
for example.
So this was three pieces we
updated.  To you, Myles.
>> MYLES BORINS: We biltd a
product with Node.
js comprised of services to
share with you today and Steren
will demo it on the machine
fowls right now.
Privilege
>> STEREN GIANNINI: Go for
it.
>> MYLES BORINS: We created a
web page watcher, and we're able
to put an address into the
submission bar, and it will
start watching it.
And at five-minute inyes mentsz,
it's
going to use headless Chrome to
take a recall -- five minute
increments, it's going on use
headless Chrome and only take
screen captures when there's
been a difference in the page.
This website allows you to set
nid number of different websites
to watch, and this has been a
lot of fun on use on like the
Google website to see the
changes to the Google header.
You could use it to watch your
own site to make sure that
things aren't going down if you
have a personal page that isn't
changing a lot.
But it was a way for us to
experiment with breaking things
into different services and put
together a really great example.
So Steren, did you have
anything you wanted to add to
that?
>> STEREN GIANNINI: I want
to tell you how it's done.
>> MYLES BORINS: That sounds
great.
>> STEREN GIANNINI: Let's go
back to the slides.  So this is
a product, this is an
application.  A website watcher.
How did we build it?
Well, every five minutes, there
is a
chron job that will trigger
first microservices.  First is
called task  scheduler, the
job of this Microservices is to
ask the database for a list of
web pages to screenshot.
When it receives this list, it
will
actual get you intie a topic a
message for each page of
screenshot.
Then it will fowsh a second
microservice -- then it will
fowsh a second microservice the
web pages and the job of this
microservice, it has one job, to
take screen shots.
So as I said previously, this is
using headless Chrome under the
hood in
order to take those screen
shots.  So it opens a web page,
takes a screenshot, saves it
into Google Cloud storage.
That's its only job.
Now the new file arrives into
Cloud storage.
This will trigger an event, this
will send an event that will
trigger a Google Cloud function
that will compare this
new screenshot with the last
known referenced screenshot for
that web page, we call it image
diff because the job of that
function is to compare two
images and if there is a
difference between the
images, it will store the new
image into a new folder in
Google Cloud storage.
So this is how we continuously
get
the updates of all of the web
pages that we want to track.
Okay.
Now, the user arrives onto a
website.
So an http request arvedz to a
web
fronted front end, another
microservice, query a list,
asking for a list of web pages,
when I see the detail of that
web page, we update the screen
shots, so it also queries Cloud
storage.  That's how we build a
product.
For custom microservices all
communicating with each other.
Now Myles is going to tell
you more a bit about the code.
>> MYLES BORINS: So the
first microservice that we're
showing is our screenshot
server.  You're going to knoll
we're using  async functions
because -- you're going to knoll
because app engine comes with no
date
out of the box, we'll start a
browder
session by awaiting puppeteer to
watch, we'll then await a new
page from the browser object,
we're going to await
surf to go that URL, we'll await
setting the viewport to the size
of the image that we want to
take and then we'll await a
screenshot in the image buffer.
We then await closing the
browser and then we return the
image buffer.  We're doing a lot
of asynchronous work in here
that is going to allow us to use
the same service to pull lots of
different images at the exact
same time without blocking.
We're able to do it in a single
linear fashion without having to
manage a whole bunch of
call-backs or any sorts of
promises, although under the
hood there's lots of different
promises going on.
Now, this is deployed using
app engine standard, and there
were some other talks going on
this week about headless Chrome
and you can find those
if you go and check the I/O web
page  later.
So this is our service that the
part of the service that actual
saves to a
bucket, similarly, we're using
asink in a way to be able to do
this in a linear fashion, but we
did to the bucket, we rename the
images to be based on a time
stamp, and we save it and await
that information and then log
it.  And because all of the
Node.js client libraries support
promises, you are going to be
able to use our various client
libraries to talk to all
of our various servers using
async await right out of the
box.
Then the last thing we wanted
to show
you was the image diff from our
Cloud function that's doing the
image diff.
Every time a new file gets add
to do a
Cloud storage bucket, this
function is automatically called
and we wanted to
show how quickly from the event
that the function is executed
with, we can grab
the file and the context at
which -- of that file inside of
Cloud storage.  So we don't even
need to write any logic to tie
the two together, we just need
one service to save it and this
new service just reacts.  One
thing that's really great about
all these different services is
that out of the box, if you
start logging, stack driver is
going to grab all those logs and
you're going to be able to use
stack driver logging to look at
all the logs of what's going on.
I don't know about you, but I
never
write a service write it the
first time, I write it locally
and will then it works
differently in the Cloud.
Being able to just log and have
it working is really awesome.
For the demo we put together,
you'll
see online later, we used bunion
and have a pretty robust logging
system you'll be able to take a
look at.
>> STEREN GIANNINI: Let's look
at the Cloud console to see
those Microservices in the
console.  As I said, we do have
three app engine services, so
you will see them on the app
engine dashboard.  So I'm
opening my services.  Oh, we
have four because I just
deployed one.  Oh, that was you?
So default screenshot and task
scheduler now.
We have one Cloud function.
See if I open it.
Image diff as you see, the
trigger is Cloud storage bucket
trigger.  Now, as Myles said,
out of the box, all your logs
are going to be collected
into stack driver logging, so
let me figure out some of those
logs and -- let me filter out
some of those logs and only
shoar the application logs that
are here.
So these are the logs for the
app across all the services, so
as you see, you are
see we loaded the website, we
also, what else did we do, we
saved screenshots, all of this
gets logged in a different
severity.
Here we had an error
apparently.
Lastly I wanted to show when
your logs go to stack driver,
they are going to be collected
and grouped together by stack
driver error reporting.  Here
what you see here is a list of
error groups, so all of your
errors, if they are the same,
are going to be grouped together
on this page as one group.  So
this is out of the box when you
use app engine especially Node.
js on app engine.
That is all for the demo of the
resources.  Let's go back to the
slides.
Now I'm going to talk a
little bit
more about how to connect
Microservices.
So of course you can directly
call a service.
So that's the case, for example,
when a client calls a front end.
So an http request arrives,
that's a direct call.  It's also
the case when you receive a web
hook.  Whul receive a web hook,
that will be a direct call.
And lastly, two Microservices
can call
each other directly, of course.
Ly another kind of communication
between
Microservices which actually can
be quite convenient and useful
is what we
call asynchronous execution and
events.
So if you remember, every five
minutes lz a service was
scheduled, so this is
one kind of scheduled services.
Now you remember anytime we
put a file into Cloud storage,
something happened, the function
was triggered.  So this is
another kind of communication,
we call that reactive services.
So when something happens, this
is
triggered via events.  Another
way to do asynchronous
execution is to actually use a
task
queue, so one service will anc
you a task into a queue and this
queue will make sure that the
task is executed by retrying if
needed and by dispatching test
rate that you want, so task
queues can be quite convenient
for asynchronous task execution.
And lastly, as we made in our
demo, you can use subscriber
pattern where one service will
publish a message into a pub
serve topic and one or many
other services that are
subscribed to that
topic will receive the message.
Lastly, maybe this is
obvious, but sharing storage is
also a way to communicate
between services.  You can have
two services sharing the same
database, that is a kind of
connection.  In our case, we
used Cloud data store and Google
Cloud storage.  So connecting
Microservices, we can
directly call them, you can use
asynchronous execution and
events and shared storage.
>> MYLES BORINS: So after
talking about all these
different types of services and
products, you may be wondering
like when should I use functions
or when should I uses app
engine or maybe when should I
use a k us bernetes?
These are decisions teams need
to make.  A little more into
functions first.  We talked
about events and async, that's a
lot of the programming model
used for this.
You have different kinds of
triggers.
There you have pub sub, Google
Cloud storage so whenever
something ends up in a bucket,
it triggers it, you can have
database transactions, one
that's interesting is logs, you
can have a function run every
time you see things in logs, you
can filter different kinds of
error messages or automate pager
duty, something like that.
Maybe not pager duty, but you
can also
use web hooks, any sort of http
can go and call it.  One of the
thing that's nice with Cloud
functions and they can really
single purpose, it has a well
defined programming model with a
really quick way to get tolt
data that's coming in
from the event, one that I
really like is an e-mailer, for
example.  You may have a whole
bunch of different services that
need to send e-mail, so if you
have one Cloud function that
just does all the off and all
the messaging to whatever e-mail
service you're running, you can
make e-mail topic on pub sub and
just publish
a to, a from, a body and a title
and an e-mail will just go out.
Let's say you decide to change
your e-mail provider service,
you just have to change that one
Cloud function and no one else
needs to refactor their code, as
long as you have defined API
service between all your
services that isn't broken, you
can change it to any
language or any service you want
to.
On the other hand, we have app
engine, app engine for example,
http
services are generally what are
exposed.
It's multipurpose, though.  You
can use it will for front end
applications, you can use it to
serve static resources, it disbt
does not are a defined function
wrapper, so you can take any
node application for the most
part that you've already been
running and just launch it.  If
you have multiple different
things that are going, multd
pell rowtsz that
you're handling, database
queries, templating, you may
find that running something on
app engine makes more sense
for the use case than a Cloud
function
but you can define your own
compute relationship.  Cloud
functions and app engine work
really great together F your
team prefers thinking about
things as functions like run
with that, I know
entire websites that have
thousands of
page views and hours and they've
written their entire
infrastructure on functions and
there's tons of big node apps
that can just run on app engine
and scale as necessary.
You could really break apart the
problem as it makes sense to
your team apples you need to go
and they both share a lot of
similarities.  They're both
going to scale to zero when
you're not using them, you're
going
to pay for what you use, and
under the hood they're using the
same sandbox, using the same
auto scaling, there's no right
or wrong.
One of the cool things about
it too is you can start thinking
it almost becomes more of a
differences of how you wanted to
think about your compute and how
you want to factor your code,
but from an ops perspective
they're very similar.
We also wanted to announce today
that node date is going to be
coming to GCF really soon,
you'll be able to use all these
features both on Cloud functions
as well as app engine.
>> STEREN GIANNINI: All right.
To recap, deploying Node.
js Microservices serverless
Node.js Microservices.  What
have we seen today?
First, breaking up the monolith.
So as you've seen, we've built
an
entire product made out of very,
very
simple pieces, each of these
pieces is a
few files or even one file for
some of them.  Break up the
monolith.  Microservices
architectures can help you build
rich product from a decoupled
small, scalable, maintainable,
understandable components.
Second, we showed you a preview
of Node.js on app engine
standard environment.
This is coming in a few weeks.
Lastly, what you should remember
is that Google Cloud platform
has
everything you need to build it
serverless Microservices using
Node.
js, and personally, I can't wait
to see what we'll build with
Node.js a.m. engine standard and
all of those products.
(applause)
.
>> MYLES BORINS: Thank you.
So if you enjoyed the session,
you can go and get your feedback
here through the schedule link.
You can use web or Android or
Kirk's OS, let us know what you
think.  Here are some resources,
you'll find the docs for the
a.m.
engine standard, you'll see the
functions and the dem mole that
we were
showing you today is all there
-- the demo that we were showing
you today.
Just a quick round of
applause for everyone who is
watching at home on the live
stream.
(applause).
>> MYLES BORINS: And one
more quick round of applause,
you don't really see t but
there's some amazing people at
the back of house in the back
here who have been working all
day tirelessly, just a round of
applause for them.
(cheers and applause).
So don't go yet.  Hold on.
>> STEREN GIANNINI: One more
thing.  One more thing.  Look
under your seat.  No, joarking!
(laughter).
Look over there.
We have a stand where you can
scan
your badge and we'll send you
invites to try tomorrow or as
soon as we get your e-mails
Node.js on app engine standard
environments, so if you wanted
to give it a try, scan your
badge over there.  Thank you.
>> MYLES BORINS: Thank you.
(The session concluded at
4:07 p.m.
)